à à
anh alo face
anh chắc bây giờ hơi sớm nghỉ hả Có một
bạn đâu ạ à à
tất cả các bạn bây giờ tranh thủ chào
Chào được mấy ông này gửi chưa có ai cả
à
à Hôm nay không nhận sớm thế mà buổi hôm
nay mình nghĩ là nó sẽ ra dạ dày nhai
mình sẽ bình luận ghi lại
buổi hôm nay sẽ rất dài à
à à
Ừ đúng rồi Bộ hôm nay sang CRD luôn rồi
kìa như mình đã nói rồi kìa à
Ừ mình dậy ppr là chỉ ở mức Cơ bản
cái cái khóa này thì cơ bản nên là không
cần được đi sâu vào rất nhiều cái mình
chỉ cần việc à Dùng pp thể thao tác Với
Form lấy dữ liệu từ trong form rồi in ra
hiển thị ra các thứ thứ được
Anh
thành ra là nhiều bạn thì nếu mà mới học
thì công nhận thấy pp nhảy sang p sang
CRD còn rất là nhanh nhưng mà như mình
đã nói thì mình đã dậy các bạn thế nào
là ngôn ngữ lập trình từ hồi mà dạy ra
Suite rồi đúng không ạ nghĩa là về ít
theo vòng lặp rồi Thế nên là bây giờ gần
như là mình không cần được ôn lại cái
đấy nữa Mình chỉ cần chỉ cần kiểu Xem sự
khác biệt nữa pp với với ra Swift là gì
cũng mặc cả
Ừ nhưng mà công nhận thì nếu mà bạn mà
mới học thì công nhận ngay từ buổi hôm
trước đã thấy em nó sẽ có gì đó nó thơ
choáng hồi toàn bộ hôm nay xác định xác
định là nếu mà các bạn chưa biết gì thì
hôm nay sẽ rất là choáng vì hôm nay của
mình là đầy đủ tính năng xem thêm sửa
xóa cload thành ra nó sẽ rất là
A và mình đấy Mình vừa ghi mà lại bỏ mày
sẽ rất dài Vì ạ mình còn đang định mà
tâm sự ngay từ bây giờ minh định Thực ra
là tâm sự từ buổi bây giờ mình chứ Bây
giờ mình mình nhớ là những cái điều này
thì mình tâm sự à
A và tí mình dạy học nữa cũng phải giữ
dài nữa
Ừ tí mình có trả lời mấy câu này nữa này
sẽ rất là dài nữa
ở phía trước mắt trước khi tâm sự tuổi
trò mày Ông xem cái này tôi mới
thôi mình xem cái bài chia sẻ này
A và
tí rồi cũng giải thích cho béo Tại sao
tôi thích kiểu tâm sự nhiều Thế đã vẽ
chỉ cần dạy học và đủ rồi nóng lạnh
ở đầu tiên là sẽ cho ông xem bài này mẹ
em bé Ông thấy màn hình tôi chị ạ
3 cách để mở tắt cái này nổi tiếng tắt
chọn inspect nóng lạnh
Mở Zing
em bận Đại Tỷ Tỷ lệ thủy
Ừ Thế màn mình hơi to rồi
khi sex
khi
chọn này Tác hại cả cái này đi
Chi tại tôi đang không đăng nhập nên nói
Hiển thị như thế này cây rồi
Ờ Ờ
cái này
Ừ chắc nhiều trai nhắn tin với em lắm ha
không đến lượt anh mất rồi còn chai nhắn
tin cho tôi thì sẽ như thế này cái này
vui nhá là cảnh báo trước nhé trong này
rất là bậy bạ phù hợp cho mấy ông nào
mùng 18 tuổi xem này bao nhiêu thì tội
không hi vọng và nhiều nhiều Em cấp 2 có
3 ngồi xem livestream của tôi đâu ạ
Ừ tôi sẽ không đọc mấy câu hỏi đâu biết
nó nhận cảm à
à à
a review
vụ tai nạn đây cũng là một trong những
cái thứ mà tui từng nói với ông ấy nếu
không mở được nhận mình kiểu là một con
người không tồi tệ vãi chưởng rồi mong
cái mong được hát chấp nhận kiểu nó kiểu
Em có nghe bị ngược cái kiểu Tại sao con
gái phải thích những kịch kiểu cái ông
mà tự ti thì không cần em xấu trai em
nghèo em ngu các giờ có cứ yêu em đi
về cây có 7 triệu rưỡi thằng ngu Nó tự
tay bóp mình thôi đúng ạ ạ
khi người ta thường xấu xấu thì không
hẳn lại trai đi với kiểu dạng này hẹn hò
đấy các bạn không nên kiểu lừa dối nhau
là kiểu khoe mình giàu thư da không phải
ý tôi không phải thế mà là mấy ông
anh cũng phải thể hiện mình thấy mạng
cái gì đó chứ không phải kiểu như này
không ạ
Ồ không Tôi thấy nơi bạn qua thư cho bỏ
qua vậy
ờ ờ
Ê thằng đầu này nghĩ tôi người Trung
Quốc
Ừ cái này cũng hơi bậy
à à
Ừ
hôm qua tôi dậy đọc cái cười sặc sụa
anh không nhận mà mày không Mày ngồi
nghĩ thì cạn kiệt
tự hào tôi cảnh báo có lại bậy rồi mà
nhưng mà cái này nó hài vì cái người nào
mà có quen được bậy quen cái sự thật
thôi mà tôi và ở dưới Cho xem cái có lý
do nó gà
vừa để giải trí vừa kể việc tôi đang
muốn trong mấy ông tự
tự tự xe mà cảm nhận cùng tôi xem nó nói
như thế nào
Anh hiểu tí mình có thể bàn luận cái gì
đó nó Nó là kiểu một cái cộng cộng đồng
ý Kiểu mình thì ở ngân hàng giống kiểu
gái xinh thế chúng ta hãy vừa xem cái gì
đó cũng nhau do người cậu cùng đánh giá
một cái gì đó cũng hay mà
à à
[âm nhạc]
em nhắn luôn cả
anh nhận luôn cả
danh sách tên sách đi siêu thị gửi cho
gái
anh ở đây cái cô ấy
thiết kế hoạch kéo thanh niên công suất
không đợi được sau 3 tiếng
à à
Ừ cái cái thế
Ừ ok và à à
Nếu như mình có nói chắc là nếu thế mình
nói qua về cái định hướng của mình trước
phải cái nghề đi ạ
Cái định hướng ở kênh mình ấy không Hôm
qua mày còn nghĩ thêm vài cái ý tưởng
đâu cũng
anh cũng tương đối ổn nữa đấy mình ổn
không biết bây giờ mình nói các bạn thì
thấy thế nào
đó đó là cái kênh mình về sau lâu dài
như mình đã nói đó là mình sẽ các bạn sẽ
là những sinh viên đầu tiên của mình
trong cái khóa này và chắc là cũng Sinh
viên cuối cùng của mình được bình bình
luận những cái buổi khóa Dạy trực tiếp
như thế này Tại sao vì về sau mình có
thể mình vẫn sẽ dạy lập trình Nhưng mà
mình sẽ không dậy à những cái những cái
này nữa mình định ở như thế Thế kênh
YouTube mày sẽ để làm gì Để ông ạ kênh
YouTube này sẽ tôi không bán hay không
gì cả mà là tôi sẽ sẽ có lại một
livestream thỉnh thoảng sẽ livestream để
cốt một cái gì đó
thứ hai là tôi nghĩ là sẽ cậu thực là
tôi gửi trước ở Tôi rất thích là tôi tôi
cũng nói tôi khá hâm mộ anh Jay v e và
Mai Cha tôi cũng sẽ có thể nhảy sang cái
mạng là milocker được lợi thế là theo
cậu ạ số vietlott thì ra là nghe thấy
cái khái niệm Vlog được nhiều người dùng
không chuẩn lắm cái Vlog là chuẩn là
ngày nào ông cũng sẽ phải Đăng cái video
rồi đó
Ừ Nó là kiểu nhật ký này còn tôi thì tôi
nhưng mà nó lại Khải miếu hiểu là sẽ
thỉnh thoảng đang có video không phải
với cuộc sống của tôi đâu
cho tôi Tôi nghĩ là sẽ hạn chế vụ đấy mà
lại sẽ là cậu hướng đến kiểu có thể tâm
sự nói chuyện gì đó
thành đương nhiên là có thể về cả công
nghệ và có thể là chỉ nạn tâm sự theo
góc nhìn của một lập trình viên thì hãy
như thế nào ạ
anh em nhà mẹ mày cái chủ đề mà tôi đang
định nói này Ok Thế
Ừ thì cũng giống như là các viêm đa cơ
khác mà mày không xem thôi Tôi tôi không
định hướng là làm hẳn là vinegar lắm anh
Bởi vì sao Bởi vì cả
chợ rõ là vừa rồi tôi vừa nói cái đoạn
này mấy ông sẽ thấy tôi nói chuyện với
mâu thuẫn thế như có lý do nào cả nhé
Đây cái dụ điển hình là giống như hôm
qua bạn gái tôi nói ngoài anh mình hai
người nổi tiếng à thôi bảo không anh từ
trước là anh rất ghét thành người nổi
tiếng bởi vì sao Bởi vì ai đó
ở cuối video Kéo 5 người nổi tiếng Nhớ
Rất phải cẩn thận ăn nói rồi Kiểu
mình mà tự nhiên có cái phốt gì đâu Chết
các thứ tư ảnh hưởng đến nhiều cuộc sống
của mình cũng thầm như người cổ người
nổi tiếng sẽ rất dễ bị cám dỗ sẽ bị có
những cái thứ gì đó có tiền bạc có hư
nữa đó làm ảnh hưởng đến cái mục đích
ban đầu của mình ạ Các bạn hình dung
em đã từng có nhiều người nói về cái vụ
người nổi tiếng thường như anh độ
Mission à hay là thật chia cái anh hùng
mà cứu được bé thứ tòa nhà cao tầng mày
không biết vụ đâu thì anh ấy cũng bảo là
kiểu rất sợ thành người nổi tiếng
anh và tôi tôi cũng hiểu cảm ba ngày anh
sẽ cho cả không muốn
Anh không muốn cho thành người nổi tiếng
chứ cả nhưng mà tôi lại anh cũng không
thể là nó là không muốn ai biết đến cả
Bởi vì nếu mà kiểu Muốn sống ẩn danh
không ai biết thì sẽ ăn tôi không
livestream như này không cậu
10 kiểu công khai thông tin ở trên
Facebook đúng không ạ
bố mẹ tôi chỉ muốn thành một con người
có tấm ảnh hưởng theo kiểu họ vì nó có
khái niệm làm micro info
influence ơi là người có tầm ảnh hưởng
nha bé không hẳn lại lớn lắm rồi đấy
ngon còn Linh form tôi phải nghĩ lại mỗi
lần nhỉ quên đó
anh
Linh đăng ký
làm đồ án
theo cặp lại ạ
Ừ
Tôi muốn tải game kẻ lên này nữa
Ừ đúng rồi làm đồ án thì sẽ cả pp các
hướng nào chút à đầy đủ tất cả kiến thức
Mình đã học mà à
Ừ thì à
ở đây tôi định hướng ở sẽ thành một cái
người cho có tầm ảnh hưởng gì gì đó bởi
vì mình muốn chia sẻ kiến thuốc thì cứ
giận mình phải có người khác biết đến
đúng ạ
Ừ nhưng mà tôi ở không muốn thành người
nổi tiếng quá trước cửa là
thứ nhất là
Ừ tôi làm vẫn có gì đó Vinamilk được cả
không phải vì làm để kiếm tiền không ạ
Không phải làm kiểu thành điện biến hình
công việc của mình theo kiểu ngày nào
phải là mà kéo làm vì đam mê thôi Kiểu
là một tuần 3 lần trận chiến Nếu là sự
ốm quá gì có vấn đề gì đó Gì đó thì mình
vẫn nghỉ được mình không bị ảnh hưởng
cuộc sống bên ngoài mình không mẹ được
thì tôi như thế thì tôi thích làm cái
thế hơn
chứa nhiều người cực kì nổi tiếng theo
kiểu lại họ làm Bây giờ họ làm bất cái
gì họ đang bất kỳ cái gì cũng sẽ phải
cân nhắc rất nhiều
anh nghe cảnh sát đặc biệt mấy ông thử
nghĩ việc lái xe
em rất là mệt
Vì thế nên tôi sẽ
cho tôi Tôi chỉ muốn dừng lại ở việc
kiểu mình là người chia sẻ chia sẻ các
thứ mình thích chia sẻ cái gì chia sẻ
được những ở mấy ông thấy thì ra trên
trang cá nhân của tôi còn này là An
admin của Trang gái xinh vâng ạ thì ca
đấy không phải làm cái tấm gương sáng
lắm khi mà ăn nhiều người nhìn vào sẽ có
thể đánh giá theo kiểu lắm giảng viên
các thứ thứ ăn Min cho cái sinh
Tôi là tôi không đi thả ảnh à Không thả
tim bạn gái nào cả nhưng mà người ta
nhìn qua người ta có thể đánh giá
chị đánh giá sơ mi ra đánh giá vội yêu
thế nghĩa là kiểu thằng này chắc Trong
đầu chị mông ngực ra trạng thái sinh của
tôi chỉ có mặt thôi chẳng hạn Nếu mà
kiểu thế Béo hình Dung ạ nghĩa là cái
Ừ cái Tết người ta sẽ hiểu nghĩ xấu ngày
về mình
thì mình phải tấm gương sáng hoàn toàn
trong cái đó rõ ràng là tôi không thể là
một kệch tấm gương sáng nên tôi sẽ sợ
cái điều đấy chứ
A và cái định hướng của tôi nữa đó là
tôi sẽ cũng Hôm qua tôi còn định hướng
là tôi sẽ có thể là cắt một vài cái tôi
lại cắt một vài cái những cái lỗ tâm sự
của tôi này nọ tả một vài mẹo nhau
khi một tôi dậy này thì sẽ cắt ra để mà
làm mấy cái kiểu video ngắn để đăng lên
Tik Tok lỡ cả ở sót của YouTube chẳng
hạn Tik Tok và và cả gel của thằng
Instagram có là để nhiều người biết thêm
và đương nhiên là sẽ kèm theo link xem
full cày buổi học kiểu thế ý nghĩa tôi
thu hút tất cả mọi thứ để nói về về kênh
YouTube Thôi để để mà mọi người biết
thêm kiểu về cái khóa học này khóa miễn
phí mà bạn ạ
sau khi cấy Hôm qua bạn cái cũng bảo là
kìa gọi anh chuẩn bị làm Tik Tok cơ à
cửa kế theo kiểu giọng mỉa mai
bởi vì các bạn đều công nhận là Tik Tok
bây giờ nó cậu phải đến nữa
từ bảy đến tám phần mười gì đó đều không
ổn
thì hồ Cậu đang những cái rất là không
ổn gì đó đúng ạ để mà câu
về để mặc câu kiểu lượt xem các thứ đỡ
họ sẵn sàng bang những cái rồi đấy vẫn
gọi là chat các thứ thứ xác đúng ạ Đấy
Nếu mà tôi kiểu sẽ tôi được nó không
quan tâm mình thấy lắm chị họ Xem mạng
xã hội Tôi đang thôi tôi là dân công
nghệ thu sẽ đang lên muội mạng xã hội có
thể để mà câu công kéo về nhưng mà Với
mục đích nghe tụi nó nói với các phi lợi
nhuận nên tôi Xuka chẳng có vấn đề gì cả
Ừ anh có Nhận dạy kèm 110 cái câu trả
lời này tôi thường ai chả lớn người khác
là không theo kiểu tôi không nhận kem
dạy kèm
ai từ đầu đến cuối nhưng tôi lại rất
thường hay hay kiểu học sinh viên nhiều
lúc tối hưởng lên của bọ sinh viên à Em
muốn học lập trình không Hay là em cậu
mấy cái ông chưa học được trình hòa ông
họ lời Singapore hỏi rồi bà
chú qua nhà anh vài hôm anh kèm cho thì
chú là đam mê lập trình ngay cứ tư thế
là tôi thực ra ở rất thoải mái việc à
Ừ chắc khỏi máy việc là kiểu
mình không có thể nhắn tin cho tôi hỏi
Cá thứ hoặc à thậm chí gặp trực tiếp để
mà tôi chỉ cho đương nhiên là thời gian
thì cũng nên sắp xếp một tí cái cái vụ
gặp trực tiếp còn nhắn tin nhưng mà em
có nhắn tin thôi hả mãi tôi cứ khi nào
trả lời đó tôi trả lời luôn
à Mà ông sẽ biết được sự thật là tôi
không hiểu con người trai thế âm thanh
Tôi từng nói rồi đó là người ghét tôi
nhắn tôi gửi tôi thôi còn chửi lại cửa
mà chảnh được với ai cả đều thế
để tui tơ được bạn có một tí nhưng mà
Peter tục Em gửi hình như người Việt
dùng ít cái kênh mình mình thì mình cho
Nói tiếng Việt thì ra là cả
thì mình sẽ cân nhắc vụ đấy à
Ừ ông kia đang khuyên tôi dùng Visual
Studio code đúng không có là trả lời cho
câu kia phải
anh đang reconnect không đi cần nhà tôi
thấy ở cậu bia Ly cần toàn kéo toàn hát
rồi lên đấy Chẳng có ông Lập Trung phía
trên đấy người lớn nữa đâu ạ
à à
Em làm thế nào để lấy lại đam mê hoặc
tìm lại đam mê các bài toán là rất là
đơn giản là đối với tôi gần đây thôi có
nhận cũng đăng hơi xao nhãng Khi mà tập
trung vào dạy học ngày mà không làm việc
ở trên
ở trên trên công ty bởi vì cậu cũng bị
Hơi bị không không phải ghét code mà
chẳng qua cậu khó chịu mà khi của có cái
đoạn bất ở đó cứ bắt mình ở làm đi làm
lại thật vài tháng sẽ công nhận là Hiểu
Minh bị là thế nhưng mà cái cách
a cách ở đây thì chỉ được giảm vậy mấy
ông phải tìm Phải làm một cái gì đó mới
cho ví dụ rộng như tôi làm mấy cái tiện
ích chẳng hạn họ tôi nhảy sang cos một
cái đoạn nào đó hay hay để tôi lại cứ
lấy lại cảm hứng thôi
Ồ vãi Olympus e
a free fire mất tiền mà đúng không ạ ừ ừ
Ừ ông kia Đang nói vụ là trên trên nhóm
gì trên nhóm Anh Tuấn đang lại việc là
tôi hoàn thành công việc các thứ thử
không cao đúng không Thì được thì tôi là
muốn người cày cày rất cho ấy một ngày
có thể 345 cái tát nhưng mà gần đây có
nhiều bị lừa thì nhưng mà cũng một phần
là thôi tôi bảo rồi tôi cài phụ là thôi
Một Tôi cày cả tôi không cái tát nhưng
mà tôi cây số Giờ cốt cơ vì có những cái
mà kiểu xếp với chồng giáo tát và tự
giao tặng cho chúng tôi nên chuyện jira
nó không có cái vụ đấy nhé nói chung và
tôi sẽ làm những công việc mà kiểu chẳng
ai biết là tôi đã là vợ thế nhà thuốc
trễ là đẩy nóng cốt lên thôi à
thì các bạn nói về tí tôi ở tôi sẽ cân
nhắc sẽ đăng cả video trên đấy nữa được
có thêm nhiều mạng xã hội trúng bạn đăng
lên
Ừ ừ đúng rồi tiện thể tôi chia sẻ luôn
cái ông cho mấy ông luôn nhắc mình nhớ
tôi sẽ tôi sẽ chỉ Ông này ông luôn cái
mấy ông biết cái ít xít lên giá không ạ
Cái ứng dụng này hồi trước việc hả chị
cho tôi và đến bây giờ vẫn dùng cho
chuyện cho trứng cái trang cái sinh của
tôi đó là cay
Hình như đúng như tôi vừa nói nói ít xít
trên ráp tất cả khi mà có cái gì đó chạy
thì lập tức Cái cái sẽ có một cái gì ở
được kích hoạt
Nó giống cơ chế của chị cơ ạ Mẹ làm
chuyện à giờ sửa khi tôi đang lạnh
khi bé Tôi đang dùng nó cho Trang Cái
sim của tôi nhà ạ Tức là khi mà tôi đang
lạnh lên kệ trang Instagram của tôi này
lập tức và sẽ đăng lên mọi mạng xã hội
khác của tôi với đúng cái tiêu đề đấy và
với đúng cái ảnh đấy đấy cảm thấy ra hay
không ạ Thế nên là nhiều ông kiểu Vào
trang ngày sinh của tôi trả lại nếu
không sẽ thấy là
ở đây là thứ nhất là để trang tâm bồ Lúc
ạ thực chất là cái toàn bộ cái ảnh này
tôi đang từ Instagram xong rồi nó sẽ
đồng bộ ông cả tâm bồi đồng bộ lên cả
Pinterest này đường bộ freak này Twitter
này sao toàn bộ tất cả các chatbot của
tôi Thậm chí còn thêm nhiều mạng xã hội
nữa nhưng mà Việt Nam mình không dùng
mới in Tôi không lấy kệ đấy thôi ca tôi
còn tôi thấy có cách mạng xã hội nào tôi
được tích vào cơ thể thành ra rất nhiều
mạng xã hội ảnh nữa
thì cái cơ chế đấy nó có chơi cái gì
thời gian này nó hay phết Nó kéo khi mà
mình Để mình chọn cái cái này thì hồi
hồi trước phải nào ít phí bây giờ thì nó
mất phí rồi nhưng mà thôi cái chỗ rồi mà
nó mới ra cái cái dịch vụ miễn phí thì
tôi
Ừ tôi có đăng ký và khuấy nói cho chủ
nhiệm nên này nó chỉ mất 2 đô thôi Để
mấy hôm đăng ký quan hệ sẽ đắt hơn đăng
ký được cái gì đăng ký đứng ngơ à lúc
đầu mấy ông mấy ông thủ thì nhở chỉ có
mỗi chọn được mỗi hai cái rồi nghĩa là
ông hiện tại cơ cho hai cái thôi còn nếu
mà ông mất phí thì sẽ tạ bao nhiêu cái
cũng được thế tôi làm chị Cường Đốm
nghĩa là đẩy lên mọi trang xã hội có thể
Cứ mỗi lần Đăng ảnh thì đẩy lên mọi mọi
mạn trang mạng xã hội thì chắc à Cái vụ
tôi vừa nói với cái xót cái đăng lên
YouTube này hay đăng Instagram cho tôi
cũng sẽ nghiên cứu là một câu trời đấy
còn nếu mà không được bản Chắc cái này
thì nó vẫn trẻ cốt nữa nhé Không thì tự
mình làm thôi vẫn làm được mà không ạ
chị sẽ có hôm nào đó tôi sẽ dạy các mấy
ông về làm cái vụ này để không ạ Thế bản
thân là nó sẽ luôn nó sẽ là một con kiểu
con boss Kiểu cái thế nó sẽ tự động chạy
kiểm tra cứ 5 phút một lần kiểm tra xem
lại ông còn đang váy mới không Nếu mà có
đăng bài mới thì sẽ đẩy mạnh xã hội khác
thế xong đúng không ạ nghe cơ chế mà đơn
giản mà nó không ạ Hãy để máy tính làm
được đấy Nếu không phải cậu ngồi copy
các thứ thì em ạ đang lên mọi mạnh nên
tả giống như là
để nhiều công ty chắc chả ra nhiều công
ty thuê mấy người làm vụ đầy đâu ạ Thế à
à anh đăng một cái gì đó là kiểu phải
đăng lên mọi nên ta hẳn xong rồi phải
ghi lại toàn bộ những cái nội dung đấy
không hãy để máy tính làm điều này hết
từ A Z đúng ạ
Ê mấy ông kia có vẻ hứng khi mà tôi
hướng dẫn cốt các thứ ấy nhỉ Nếu mà Mấy
ông Khi mà tôi cốt thế xong mày không
được nói thoáng nhé ạ
em viết bằng bất cứ ngôn ngữ lập trình
gì cũng được kể cả da speak cái đã TP
hình như mình đã nói ngôn ngữ là trình
nó không nó không quan trọng
ừ ừ
Ừ cái trang thích cái bồ thật là Trang
này nó vẫn hơi đểu đấy nó không chặn lại
pi được À nó dễ bị starm số trang đấy Bị
spam liên tục
Ừ đúng rồi mình vẫn ốm Mình vẫn nha
Ừ mình sức đề kháng mình khá là 01
khuyên mày ông không nên như thôi
tôi làm tất lắm à
à à thôi Đấy nói với các định hướng và
nói chung là tôi sẽ còn cả tôi tôi sẽ
làm cái video như tôi vừa nói nó sẽ
video ngắn cắt từ mấy cái video khóa học
ngoài ra
đôi khi ở trẻ tâm sự với gì đó Cặp Nếu
nhớ cái vụ Tôi so sánh cái vụ là nun sẽ
là
tổ chức là trước chưa từng có người yêu
và không thì sẽ là có người yêu rồi
nhưng thất tình không ạ
Đấy thì tôi sẽ có thể sẽ cắt cái đoạn
video này ra để mà đăng lên để mà sao
kèm theo cái tiêu đề cái tiêu đề là kiểu
cách giải thích nun với không với MT dễ
hiểu thằng ăn gì đó Đây
đúng rồi thì tụi thì tôi Tôi nghĩ mình
cái đấy người khác có thể là cái dân
công nghệ nhìn qua có thể có thể hệ hứng
không ạ
chị đã sợ à
em tranh thủ tâm sự nốt phải cái vấn đây
nhá đầu tiên thì cái Tiên học lễ hậu học
văn đấy thì ý Mình định nói đây đó là
hôm trước mình từng nói đó là mình không
về sau giả sử Nếu mình có con
thì mình sẽ
Anh không quan tâm nó học giỏi
à mà quan tâm nó Cậu biết lễ nghĩa cái
thứ thứ
a và có vụ gần đây nó có vụ là các giáo
sư thạc sỹ gì đó nói việc là đại học bây
giờ lên à
cho nên cậu chú trọng và dạy nghề
anh và cậu nói chung là dậy chưa cậu
hình thức cơ à
Ừ để mà miễn là sau sinh viên đi làm
được
em bỏ qua những cái dạy ở lại nghĩa các
thứ mình thấy sự ra đời một trong những
cái rất là sai mấy cái á bỏ qua hàng ưa
dạy đoạn lịch sử thôi Cái địa lý gì đấy
mình ớ thế không ngờ Chính sách cụ thể
cái bài viết hay lắm nhưng thế mà trong
cái rất là sai
mình từng học cài đọc cái bài về cách
dạy học ở bên Nhật vì thời đó cấp 1 của
họ
có phải năm 1953 năm lớp 1 năm lớp 3 hay
họ không cần phải thì Cửu gì cả sinh
viên ở đấy học sinh ở đấy sẽ học toàn bộ
lịch sử
du lịch sử của Nhật đấy nghĩa họ sẽ học
tất cả truyền thống lịch sử trước khi họ
học những cái kiểu tính toán toán mình
hai cái gì đó khoa học thứ mà không cần
nói gì cơ tại Nghĩa ăn trẻ mình sẽ họ
phải học những cái đấy
Thế là mình cảm thấy à mình mình nên Thứ
nhất là bên mình bên nước mình thì có
lòng tự tôn dân tộc cũng có lớn chính
xác là lòng à
sự tự tôn được gần đây đang bị hủy hoại
rồi
Ừ tôi chỉ thấy ạ Cái cái tôi cao thôi
mình đang bị cái tôi cao
Ừ chứ không phải lòng tự tôn dân tộc mày
nữa nghĩa là không tôn trọng lịch sử
cũng như là không tôn trọng kiểu tiếng
mẹ đẻ thì vẫn vẫn
anh không tôn trọng nguồn gốc của mình
thì lòng tự tôn mình nó bị sặc cháo hoa
cái tôi cao theo kiểu lại ai nhắc tới
người Việt thì bao tự ái hay cái thứ
nhắc đến bản thân mình nhắc những thói
xấu của mình nó tự ái thì để cái tôi chứ
không phải còn lòng tự tôn lương tâm nữa
em nhìn thấy nên là cái cách cách giáo
dục bây giờ tôi nghĩa vẫn phải sửa đâu
phải cái vụ đấy nó sẽ nhất là
dạy cho học sinh từ chính giáo viên cũng
phải tâm tâm tâm huyết với mấy cái môn
đấy dạy học sinh cảm thấy đam mê đam mê
những cái môn đấy và 5 tôn trọng lịch sử
tôn trọng những cái của bản chất của
mình không ạ
cho tôi nhiều lúc tôi muốn kiểu xuống
dậy cấp 1 cấp 2 cấp 3 vãi theo kiểu dạng
được Lúc mà tôi lên dạy cho mấy ông lúc
là lại học này thì mấy ông Thực ra là có
hình thành sẵn những cái tư tưởng sẵn
những cái
anh nói chung là kiểu cái cả cái tính
cách sẵn rồi
thủ tục ghét là cái gì đó thích cái gì
đó rồi ăn ở máu rồi Thế à tôi khó sửa
được mấy ông Mười mấy cái vụ đấy
à à Nhưng mà
Cô dạy có 1 cấp 2 thì tôi không biết rõ
mệt lắm
Ừ đúng rồi giáo dục bây giờ chú trọng về
kĩ năng kĩ giáo dục bây lại chú trọng về
việc là không phải dạy người nữa mà dậy
nhiều dậy thầy à Dậy thọ nó rồi dậy
người có thể đi làm được rồi thực ra thế
mà tốt Thế cũng tốt cho cả là họ đi họ
họ đi học xong họ vẫn có thể đi làm được
giống như bên tư bản thế với Mỹ rằng ạ
Họ sẽ hiểu Dạ mà ở đó chú trọng vào kiểu
việc
cô dạy ra được Thọ
Ừ nhưng mà có chọn thì như mình nói thì
cái lễ nghĩa bị mất không ạ
anh không còn tôi không nói về vụ mấy
cái vụ liên quan đến việc này à phải
dùng dùng roi thì à
những bài học sinh ở các thứ tôi không
nói về một cái quan điểm đấy cái đấy nó
là phải trù gì đó liên quan đến cả tâm
lý học nữa thì tôi không biết
Ừ nhưng mà chắc chắn em bây giờ cái cách
dạy nào đang bị cứ nửa nằm nửa mỡ trả
học hỏi từ bên tư bạn nhiều thấy muốn
mình muốn phát triển như bên đó đi dậy
cởi hết thì ra là kiểu nó đang bị kiểu
sinh viên học sinh cũng bị thay đổi
chóng mặt không ạ
à à
a tiếp theo nãy giờ rồi cao Tôi đã nói
những cái chữ chủ đề nó vẫn khá cũng có
ngày cả nhưng mà tôi từng nói bởi vì tôi
cũng bị ảnh hưởng bởi chắc bởi anh rơi
Vy nên là anh đấy Hồi trước cũng từng ra
những cái Vlog kiểu này nhưng mỗi tội
anh ấy nói Cậu hài hước Tôi đã nói thẳng
vào vấn đề
Ừ tôi thì chắc là chưa có thời gian để
mà ngồi mình nghĩ thì việc làm mấy cái
kia hài hước nói kiểu chấm biến ở như
thế nào
Tất cả cũng sẽ cần nhắc tôi có thể nói
chuyện kiểu gì đấy Dậy đều nói rồi châm
biếm cứ nói thẳng như này thật ra không
hay lắm ông ạ ạ
a tiếp theo cả vụ về tiêm vắc xin cho nó
nhưng mà tôi mới cho tôi nói thế à Thế
ra tôi vẫn là con người yêu Đảng nha tôi
không hề nói đá xoáy gì cả tôi vẫn thôi
vỡ yêu đã yêu đất nước thưởng theo cờ đó
với mình sống nhưng mình sống ở đây mình
phải kiểu Tuần Heo nó đâu ạ Mình vẫn
thấy họ vẫn đang làm rất nhiều cái quan
điểm vẫn đúng
300 châm biếm Thì anh có châm biếm ấy
Thế em chưa gặp anh ngoài đời anh châm
biến đã đã đã xoá chứ bọn bạn nhiều phết
chả qua là việc châm biếm về mấy cái
nghĩa cả mà cho chả ra
chị sẽ rất dễ gây hiểu nhầm cũng như là
sẽ lại mất thời gian để mà làm Hà Nội
dung cho chuẩn
à à tiếp theo về vụ tiêm vắcxin không
biết mấy ông có điểm cho tôi tưởng đang
bài về vụ tiêm vắcxin rồi đó là ăn thịt
à
ờ ờ là tôi thấy thứ nhất là mình hông để
tôi thử nó lại về Cái kiến thức của tôi
về kể tiêm vắcxin nhé đó là à
khi cài vắcxin ở nó là để thử thử cho
mấy ông
có
một cái Liệu nhẹ trước về con virus đấy
để cho có thể ông quen dần với việc còn
virus đấy để mà nó kiểu nói chung là tạo
được một cái thói quả Một cái sức đề
kháng một cái quen dần rồi để lần sau
nếu mà gặp có lấy thật thì mình sẽ đối
phó với nó được theo cổ là
anh không bị nặng lẫn cả à
em thấy chút phải chỉ nói lại không bị
nặng thôi à
Ừ thế thế nên là kiểu có nhiều người bị
quan điểm sai về việc tiêm vắcxin thứ
nhất là nghĩ rằng là thế vắcxin sẽ miễn
dịch hoàn toàn về con virus thì cái đấy
sai hoàn toàn
anh Bởi vì không không có cái loại thuốc
nào với hội thể giúp cho miễn dịch hoàn
toàn cả chẳng qua là tiểu để cho ông
quen dần với nó rồi thì ông Khi mà không
gặp thật thì ông sẽ đợi bị nặng đỡ bị
nặng đúng không ạ Còn nếu mà khiêu không
tiêm chừng tiên mà gặp nó rồi thì sẽ
Ừ thì ông sẽ thấy Hậu quả nó sẽ có thể
nặng nề như nào thế nên là nhiều ông một
kêu là tiêm vắcxin mũi 1,2 xong cái Mệt
thì thì không biết được là lúc mà ông
gặp thật thì ông chắc cũng chết thẳng
chứ không phải mệt nữa Bây giờ tôi nghĩ
ai cũng phải nên từ Pepsi
chứ không phải mỗi thì gọi con virus con
An này tôi được ra từng đọc bài của Bill
Gates về rất lâu rồi không biết về ông
có biết cái video này không Đó là để pin
ghét từng lồ trước cái này trước rồi
55565 là là cái y học của mình đang bị
dậm chân tại chỗ
ạ sau ba bốn mươi năm rồi mà không có
thêm những cái loại vắcxin mới hay các
thứ thứ mà virus thì càng ngày nó sẽ nó
là bạn virus nó khác với vi khuẩn vi
khuẩn là những cái kiểu những cái cảm
cúm bình thường hãy những cái bệnh giờ
bình thường còn virus thì nó sẽ là nó bé
hơn và nó có thể phát triển vi khuẩn đến
mãi sẽ vẫn vậy nhưng virút thì nó khác
với nốt nó sẽ luôn phát triển thành ra
là vị virus có cài Cả phát triển và y
học mình bị dừng lại giận 30 40 năm rồi
mãi kể cổ Hội vụ này các bạn mới thấy
được lại đi học nó toàn như nào khi mà
gặp một con virus như thế
anh đấy anh Thành ra là
đúng rồi Bill Gates nói cái từ trên Tik
Tok rất là lâu rồi và bị ghét ở lùng
trước à là trái đất nó sẽ có hiện tượng
diệt con người có thể diệt không phải là
bởi vì giết lợn nhau mà chị bởi vì chính
vì
vì loại các loại virus
à à anh bởi và bí kết cũng cảnh báo luôn
là nếu mà loại virus đấy cách để mà lây
lan giết con người nhanh nhất thì nó
chính là qua đường hô không khí đấy Đấy
chị nó còn này đâu đúng không ạ ạ
anh không không không phải Ý mình không
phải về mỗi vọng sự phát triển về vắcxin
sự phát triển và y học đấy Nếu không để
ý kĩ là bây giờ thì y học của mình anh
bị nó bị biến tướng như thế nào ạ Đi học
bây giờ ra phát triển những cái gì đó
đang phát triển về những cây thuốc làm
đẹp những cái kiểu sản phẩm kiểu để
truyền thông minh lỡ như là khỏe mạnh
hơn thì cũng có nhưng mà kiểu chủ yếu để
làm đẹp kiểu đề mà kẹo để mà sự phát
triển cơ bắp để phép triển cái gì đó
Ừ đấy mình mình đang bị hướng đến không
phải hướng đến nữa về để cứu người hay
để mà kiểu gì đó nữa nghĩa là cái kính ý
ý của mình nghĩa là cái tập trung tập
trung của cái y học đấy nó bị nó bị
hướng đến được đầu tư vào những cái mảnh
mà nó không phải là mảng cứu người
các bạn hình Dung ạ
ví dụ là bây giờ còn đang đầu tư là sử
làm gì con đất nước nào bây giờ động từ
mạnh nền y tế rồi đúng không ạ Giống như
là
anh không không phải của mình nó nhé của
cả thế giới nói chung ấy kiểu có rất ít
nước vừa rồi sau đợt vừa rồi mới cảm
thấy là kiểu đi học nhiều nước toa vãi
chưởng theo như Mỹ rằng ăn để không phải
mỹ đầu tư rất nhiều vào quân sự nghĩa
súng đối ngoại đấy
khi lần đầu tư và súng sợ đầu tư là giết
người nhiều hơn đấy Sau đó thì khi và
vừa rồi nó chứng minh em điều lạ y học
của Mỹ là toanh như nào các bệnh viện là
toa như nào Đúng
anh ạ
Ừ cái đấy thì vấn đề chung của thế giới
không phải mỗi của mình không ạ
ý
chính trong năm vừa rồi là cái năm kích
thích cảo nền y học và cả về công nghệ
hai nước những nước nào lạc hậu về công
nghệ giống như là thậm chí giống chính
cả nước mình cũng lạc hậu về công nghệ
theo kiểu là không áp dụng công nghệ vào
trong bài toán về trình chính phủ về
quản lý đúng ạ Đấy Thạnh thành ra là
kiểu năm vừa rồi rất nhiều cái phải thay
đổi rất nhiều Mô hình để thay đổi chính
phủ có phải áp dụng công nghệ vào xong
rồi phải phải phát sinh ra những cái ứng
dụng áp cấp Thể thứ để mình rà soát dữ
béo thấy năm vừa rồi là năm
em phải có một cái động lực như thế để
đòn bẩy đẩy thế giới lên đầu thế giới về
nên đi học và đầu thế giới về nền công
nghệ lên chứ không thì à
Ừ thế giới được ra là đang bị
ví giặm Trần khá lâu rồi từ cái thời mà
đua nhau làm mà tên lửa hồi đấy cũng đẩy
nên công việc lên rất là nhanh sau đó
lại chững lại Bây giờ thì mấy ông thấy
bây giờ các công ty đang tập trung làm
gì ạ làm thêm những con à điện thoại cao
cấp hơn để bạn chơi được nhiều game hơn
hoặc những con laptop để mà chơi được
nhiều game hơn đúng ạ thế giới đầu tư
tất cả những người đấy mà đầu tư thêm
súng ống Cá thứ không đầu tư thêm những
cái những cái giáo dục này hay những cái
những cái vẫn và nơi khác
Ê mày ông thấy Hậu quả rõ ràng đấy rồi
còn gì nữa
Ừ tôi Thỉnh thoảng tôi bị triết lý một
tí thì uống thuốc à à
[âm nhạc]
Ê mày mà có Đây là mất mấy cái có không
gian thôi
vũ trụ có thử thôi nhá Còn không thì
chẳng có công ty đầu tư đâu mấy ông thầy
có thấy thế em ạ chỉ đầu tư thêm nhiều
vệ tinh để mà kẹo phủ sóng
phủ sóng 4G có sự thứ rồi
à à Thôi bây giờ vào buổi học thôi nha
bị giỏi quá rồi
từ
nãy giờ thực ra tôi đã nói là trường có
điểm của tôi thổi không biết là tôi nói
có đúng hay sai nữa Nhưng mà tôi nghĩ là
tôi
chắc là cũng đúng phần được hiểu là theo
theo lý thuyết theo những cái kinh dị
cái tôi biết ở thế à
Xin chào bạn kia nói đúng cái bên danh
rồi đấy Ba hấp bia này như thế Tôi xin
trả tôi nghĩ những cái đao to búa lớn
như thế chả rồi rõ ràng mình có thể mình
trả lại quyết luôn đi bình trà một thằng
lập trình viên máy nhỏ thôi
Ừ thôi quay quay lại buổi học hôm nay
thứ nhất là hôm nay tôi định chia sẻ cho
mấy ông thêm à hạng hai cái này ra để về
sau tôi chưa sẻ ông sao rồi tôi sẽ bị
chỉ ghi chú bạn hôn nhá à
ở đầu tiên thì có bạn hỏi về cái này đó
là
ờ ờ Facebook
Ô cái con này của mình ấy mình mình
thường dịch ra theo ý khác nhá một cái ý
cái ở Tổng quát hơn đi là
thì
tại sao giờ vẫn còn nhiều trang web
thì sẽ bị hack
thì rõ ràng giờ mainboard
phổ biến rồi và
à à
vì nó có những biện pháp phòng chống rồi
cơ mà ạ ạ
[âm nhạc]
Ở đây Ờ ờ
Ừ để trả lời câu này của bạn đấy hôm
trước mà thấy có hỏi là kiểu kiểu kiểu
tôi sẽ dịch ra Nó kiểu như này thì
như tôi Tôi không biết tôi từng nói mấy
ông chưa là mấy rồi dân phải đến 70 phần
trăm lần thôi xem gần nhất là 70 phần
trăm trang web ờ ờ Đức trên toàn thế
giới ở tạo bởi TP ở trong đó tận cũng
lại 70 80 phần trăm và tạo bởi grad hoặc
à Dung ra những cái kiểu
cái mình từng nói qua nó là brotform kéo
thả để tạo ra một trang web đúng ạ
Chứ không phải là phê work tất cả sao là
những kẻ flashform này thì đầy lỗ hổng
yêu kiểu là bởi vì nó là chắp vá của rất
nhiều cả cái tiện ích cắt plug-in nên là
nó đầy lỗ Hồng và lợn chứa có nhiều rất
nhiều trang web nó còn lâu lắm không
được cập nhật hay ra là nó giống như cái
Windows của mấy ông mày ông thì họ không
cập nhật thì có hacker là mò được cái
lỗi gì đó là con ngựa toàn bộ những
người dùng là dùng các phiên bản Windows
lấy lệ bị chết
à à
anh nói chung à Về thứ nhất là không có
hệ thống mà an toàn
kiểu dáng xinh bạn sẽ mò được những cái
mất gì đó Những cái lỗi gì đó và thể từ
đấy sinh ra những cái lỗ Hồng
Ừ đúng ạ
bộ phim Quốc thì đương nhiên là như mình
vừa nói nó sẽ là kiểu đó chặt chẽ hơn
bởi rất nhiều người cùng làm là
vào nó cập nhật thường xuyên hơn nằm
form và Nó kiểu như các bạn nó đã có
những cái biện pháp phòng chống tốt hơn
thằng lát tôm phải thằng perform về cơ
bản nó nó hơi bị tạp nham như mình vừa
nói nó Nó là kiểu chắp vá của rất nhiều
còn loại ai nó hạ thủy một một plug-in
và blog in thì người ta duyệt Thế là dễ
còn phê Wechat cho nó sẽ với cẩn thận
bởi vì nó tích hợp vào trong lòng
Facebook đấy đấy xảy ra là kiểu facebook
khó bị hack hơn còn smartphone thì đầy
đầy hack Ừ
thế thế nên là bây giờ có rất nhiều
trang có thể bị hack đơn giản lấy rồi
nhưng mà hôm trước cũng có ông đang ở
trên đó như tim community Lại khoe thêm
một em 2k bạn hay 2006 2008 gì đấy khách
được trang chính phủ ông ạ xong Còn mấy
ông kia thì kiểu bình luận ở dưới cả lại
Ừ vậy em đi ngủ thế có sự Xứ
Ừ Từ từ khen như thế nó vừa hay vừa giờ
Ừ thế thì đương nhiên là mẹ ông ấy làm
được một cái đấy chắc chắn ra ấn tượng
rồi đúng ạ theo kiểu với người không
biết tí gì là sự nhưng mình không biết
khách thì hãy sao rất ấn tượng chứ rồi
Chỗ rất là giờ thì cậu lại
Em làm thế để đạt được nhu cầu người ta
đó là người ta thường là những hacker
người ta sẽ rất thích khoe mẽ cờ là họ
làm cái gì đó như thế rồi được người
khác công nhận thì sẽ sướng
lại càng khiến cho nhiều Em muốn ngầu
trong mắt người khác lại muốn học hành
hacker nữa không ạ ạ
A và hacker hacker như thế thì nó đỡ nhớ
sàn sai đúng ạ a hacker bé hay cơm gỗ
đen hỏi hay cơm bụi trắng 2 cường độ
sáng với được vinh danh quán hay cơm mũ
đen thì nó làm những cái kiểu say sáng
như thế Không hề tốt đưa nhà hay cười
một đêm các bạn thường ấy thấy nó sẽ nổi
hơn 2 + trắng mũi trán thì nó làm ở công
ty bảo mật đúng ạ Mà nó sẽ ra cậu để mà
vá những cái lỗ hổng và gần như chả ai
biết đến cả còn hai con màu đen là đi
hack ở những cái trang khác về mà Làm gì
mà kiếm về cái gì đó hoặc cả để mà đấy
để mà làm mình thành người nổi tiếng
nhiều người biết đến hơn nhưng mà chính
vì lí Thế thì ra là cả
áo kiểu thời gian là
tổ miếu chích đi làm phát hơn không ạ
hai mẹ con lên những cái kiểu thế Tôi
nghĩ là không nên
à à
a hacker mũ đen ở được chính phủ luôn à
Thì Nếu thế thì bạn sẽ hiểu nó hai cái
mũ xám còn thường gọi là Mũ á nó dai dai
mũ Xám này mũ Nghi đối với thế tức là
sao nó là nó là hai cơ cả mũ trắng và
màu đen nghĩa là vừa làm bảo mật cho
chính phủ của mình vừa đi thử thách
những cái tập đoàn hóa chính phủ của
nước khác có tiền Hình mấy hôm Trung
Quốc hạ nó không Trung Quốc đi bắn Dạ
nếu mà Mấy ông xem cái trang là hack mát
như vậy
mấy ông sẽ thấy là
a
hectic cân à
em có cái Chanh vì nó bấm liên tục xe
kiểu à
a free time hack kinh map Day
em có cái trang này lên để xem liên tục
à
khi liên tục kiểu cánh nước đang khách
lẫn nhau như thế nào Người không Xem mô
hình thì mày ông dễ hiểu
Ừ tôi rất hay gõ nhầm chữ hack mạng
tôi quên xử cái Trang đấy rồi
em phải buồn có cái chanh để xem viettai
mơ mấy ông sẽ thấy bắn bắn bắn bắn như
kiểu kiểu máy bay bay sang nước khác đi
bắn nhau liên tục
á quân sự mất rồi
Ừ hình như sau này
xe tải bắn nhau liên tục
Em hãy mấy ông sang sang đây xem mà là
chị giống như là bắn tên lửa nhau ấy
an toàn chủ yếu là Mỹ Mỹ bắn thằng Pháp
thả các bạn lại nghĩ là xong rồi nha là
sôi Trung Quốc liên tục bắn nhau này sao
rồi thực ra là Việt Nam mình cũng đi bắn
nước khác vào nước khác bản nước mình
nhiều lắm
[âm nhạc]
anh em uống say mày đi rót liên tục bắn
keo này trong giải trí Mà nó à à à
số
trang hệ thống kê trang hệ thống kê bản
chất là Trang này bắt gói tin mạng kiểu
cổ Hoài tim vào đó kiểu có vấn đề gì đó
bắt thôi mà chắc thế hệ tôi chịu à tiếp
theo
à tại em bây giờ phấn dạy học của cậu
Khi một cái được vì sao rồi có hỏi xin
lỗi
[âm nhạc]
nói nốt về cái vụ đồ ăn à
Anh Nguyễn Linh à lại méo đi xem bắn
nhau gì Ok
mày ông thích thì ra nét mà Mở rồi bảo
tao đang bận tất cả nước này cho nó
không ạ ạ
ờ ờ ờ nói về cái vụ đồ án tại tôi sẽ ghi
lại làn cho mèo
ừ ừ
à à
Vì sao nó biết được đó tin có vấn đề
chắc là mấy ông phải hỏi nếu hệ cơ thôi
Ở Dân lập trình cho chịu
a a Ok
đồ án thứ nhất là
Ừ nó đề tài là gì này đề tài này ạ
số tự nhiên có quyền sử rồi đợi tí Ok
anh sửa phải ghi phải ghi cụ thể những
cái gì rồi
đỡ thôi tí nhé
đó là mục đích của đồn ấy ý thôi như thế
các bạn không tính nha
à à
ừ ừ
Ừ rồi hình như tôi xóa sư với Vi anh xóa
sử cái đấy rồi trò chơi tôi ghi lại vậy
một này về đề tài này tin tức hoặc cả
Bán Hà
hoặc cả một cái gì đó nữa
nhờ người yêu cầu yêu cầu của trang web
đấy sẽ là gì sẽ là
nhất là
đầy đủ tính năng
could này để giải quyết một bài toán
ờ ờ
khi đăng nhập
là có
chú ý nhất hai đối tượng sử dụng
dụng khách hàng tất cả quản lý này à
khi đăng nhập
phải có tính năng liên quan đăng nhập
này đăng ký này Nó chẳng đúng à
Ừ để lọc liên quan đến xuân
ừ ừ
Ừ có gì đó nha Ừ đón muộn thì cần các
bạn như thế
ừ ừ
ở
thời gian
hai đến ba tháng à
vì
số lượng thành viên
khi hai người I
chủ
đề tài tôi có chấm chấm ở đây mấy ông có
thể nghĩ các đề tài khác à đây đấy Đúng
rồi công nghệ áp dụng
atl
+
Speed
toàn + pp Toàn
Ừ
nếu có thời gian
thêm thì có thể dùng
có gj
Tại sao phải có Đề cập về vụ này ở đây
bởi vì à Nếu mà bạn muốn
đôi khi là bạn sẽ có thể chèn thêm một
vài cái gj về theo cậu là làm cái slide
show hoặc là làm cái Kiều có bát mở lên
để hiển thị thì mình muốn cho phép còn
không được dùng bút pháp không dùng
phương thuốc vào đó để mà Cút nhanh có
mượn cái thứ thứ
anh khóc tạm thời bỏ qua mày đấy không
được không được dùng mpc không được dùng
Oppa các bạn sẽ phải quen dần với việc
Cốt phần đã bởi vì đề khóa cơ bản mà nó
gọi E
à còn gì ông nhỉ
I phone chữ 2 icon bên ngoài mình cái
thư viện
được được phép sử dụng là
ờ
thư viện CS bên ngoài được được
anh
vẫn được
thế nhưng nhưng mà như mình đã nói gì
không được dùng Facebook nào thôi không
được dùng Facebook Wechat hôm nó dùng mà
Facebook ra quyết vào đó còn các bạn
chèn thêm các thư viện
Ừ thế thì mình sẽ nói chung đi nếu có
thời gian thì có thể chèn thêm ribery à
xây dựng rét hoặc xếp được
A và cuối
cuối tuần này tôi sẽ
Ừ thôi sẽ chạy chạy random sau tất cả
mình ông để mà tôi sẽ chắc là gửi mail
cho mấy ông để mấy ông tự liên hệ với
nhau nếu loại liên hệ với nhau
em tự chủ động thôi
Ê mày không nhớ đi mô tô cũng cho này
nhá
Anh đừng có phải điên Cái phom kia mày
coi
Ê tôi dậy về ra Suối phần nữa là pp phần
cho tôi chấm cho mấy ông rồi một cái này
không Tôi vừa nói đấy không biết đây cho
tôi ghi rõ lại không Facebook
không mvc em không ngủ đây
bữa
C2 ok à
Ê
bà dùng ngôn ngữ khác zava hai cái gì đó
thì tôi
anh cũng cũng không không chấm mấy ông
đó
Ừ ông bị ông tham gia khóa học của tôi
béo Vậy ôm ôm kiến thức ở chỗ khác về để
mà béo Smart và bây giờ rồi thế tôi tôi
dậy mấy ông làm gì không ạ Không tôi
không chơi như thế với ông mấy ông tham
gia của tôi ở mấy ông phải theo for tôi
chứ đúng không để mà tôi đánh giá đường
làm với ông học hành của tôi như thế nào
chứ Bây giờ tôi dậy ông p rồi ông đòi
đòi chấm bằng Java
thì thì chứng tỏ là mấy ông học ở nơi
khác về rồi mong tôi chấm Thế là dở rồi
Ừ
đúng rồi đã sắm Chị ơi mày Ông đang đi
làm ở công ty mày không ôm xử cái gì đó
ở công ty về thì cũng không được đúng ạ
nói chung à Đây là sân chơi theo kiểu là
các bạn phải khởi đầu bằng nhau đương
nhiên ông là có kiến thức rồi nhưng nhà
ông có lợi thế nhưng mà mình không phải
dành thời gian để mà tự làm lại một cái
gì đó đúng không ạ Đây
Ừ
nếu anh cũng bắt đầu nghĩ dân với mấy
cái này trước đi đúng ạ
à À đấy Xong rồi và tôi sẽ cho bé uống
xem luôn qua về cái á
xe tải tôi sẽ cho ông xem về à quy trình
bảo vệ oán
em
có cả quy trình bảo vệ đoàn nhé á
à Mà thôi chắc là tạm thế này đã
ở TD
hơi bị nhiều kiến thức quá mấy ông bị
quá tải tôi nói
cần có
từ
tài liệu
ở bản Word
mô tả
anh về
sơ đồ án
phiên
bản PowerPoint
gì
để thuyết trình à
à à
Chỉ có tôi sẽ phải dạy các bạn các thứ
thứ dại hết cả về các thứ như thế này
Đấy
chưa chỉnh
Cả hai đều phải chương trình à
the first Tôi đùa mày không ạ Đây là một
cái đoàn Thật sự tôi dậy rồi ông mà em
cách viết word này cách xa PowerPoint
cho rằng tôi sẽ chỉ nói qua mấy ông nên
tránh gì con tôi không phải dậy mấy ông
ngồi cả PowerPoint nữa gửi dậy mấy hôm
qua boss xong mày không Rập khuôn đồng
nhau thì xong lại buồn quá còn về cách
viết tài liệu của tội sẽ dạy mấy ông
người cách ghi tài liệu đấy
Ừ tôi sẽ dạy mày ông là cách có cả sơ đồ
hữu cơ thực thể và sơ đồ quan hệ thực
thể nữa
và sơ đồ cơ sở dữ liệu nữa
có hết nó dậy hết tất cả mấy ông đồng
ngay đúng không ạ Và nói cho mấy ông cứ
sẵn sàng tư tưởng sẵn về mấy cái này
trước đi mày ông nghĩ trước về đề tài đi
Ít nhất là như thế để mà hôm chủ nhật
tôi ghét cho mấy ông thì bị ông bật ra
luôn lạ với với cộng sự của mình không ạ
để mà
u80 nhắc nhở quên cộng với mét ý em ạ
ừ ừ
xe máy quẹo nha à
nhà thiết kế đã tạo bay thì tôi sẽ thiết
kế cho mấy ông mẫu về bán hàng và cả tin
tức Nhưng mà đợi em mấy ông có thể mời
ông có thể tự tùy chỉnh đây những cái
cần lưu ý
lưu ý là
ừ ừ
có hạn kiểm tra
kiểm tra định kỳ
hàng tuần
mỗi nhóm trả lại cho tôi phải tốn thời
gian để kiểm tra mấy ông mấy cái vụ này
Ừ để xem tiến trình của từng nhóm đang
đến đâu cũng như là
nếu anh có đang đi đúng hướng hay không
Tại vì rõ là tiến độ
à Cậu lộ trình có đã đúng rồi không này
A và
ờ ờ không
được
tự ý sửa data pay
đâu ạ nghĩa là các bạn sẽ
cho
các bạn sinh viên mình bao nhiêu thẳng
bao nhiêu bao nhiêu rồi bao nhiêu khóa
rồi luôn tự ý sửa ra ta bây Khi mà mình
đã duyệt rồi Kiểu nữa nha các bạn khi
đang cốt giờ một cái gì đó các bạn sẽ
nghĩ thêm tính năng nghĩ là cái này của
mình muốn làm thêm người này hay mình
cảm thấy cái này khó quá mình bỏ qua gì
đó
Ừ thì các bạn cũng sẽ phải hỏi lại người
có kinh nghiệm về việc
anh thay đổi là tao bay vì 38 bay mình
dậy mình dạy dạy các bạn theo mô hình
Thắng nữa tất cả sao là làm hết toàn bộ
phân tích thiết kế ra bay sau đó nhảy
sang cốt tháng nữa tất cả trạng chảy từ
trên xuống dưới tức là làm xong cái đấy
thì không được phép Quay lại cái trên
nghĩa là các bạn đến phần cốt rồi các
bạn không được phép
anh quay lại cái phần sửa đã giơ tay
biểu ngoại bởi vì nó ảnh hưởng rất nhiều
có thể cả bạn thì nghĩ rằng là nó cái
đoạn đấy em sửa chỗ khác cũng cái là
xong đúng không ạ nhưng mà không Mình
phải quen với cái việc là làm việc như
thế theo mô hình thác nước là phải như
thế
em hiểu ạ Chứ về sau ông vào một cái dự
án lớn mà ra theo mô hình như thế nào
nào đấy
tự nhiên ông sửa về B
Ừ ông bán nhà điều không bán được rồi
à à
làm
slime với thác nước là là nó sẽ mỗi xanh
nó đều có thế mạnh riêng của nó và mình
sẽ mình thường ở mình sẽ dậy rồi sinh
viên theo dạng là thác nước chứ không
phải spam nhưng mà đương nhiên là các
bạn thấy là mình cũng có kiểm tra định
kỳ các thứ thứ và mình nếu mà trong một
vài trường hợp của các bạn muốn sửa mình
sẽ hỗ trợ các bạn để sửa nên là nó hơi
bị lừa năng lượng mỡ và gì chứ không hẳn
là thác nước hoàn toàn nhưng mà nhưng mà
Đúng là các bạn mới học thì nên là thác
nước để mà đỡ phải tốn quá nhiều thời
gian Bởi vì bây giờ nếu mà các bạn đang
quy ước là 23 tháng sau một cái dự án
đúng không ạ Nếu mà đến tháng thứ 2 tự
nhiên các bạn muốn sửa một cái tính năng
gì đó một sửa đã đây thì thời gian để
làm một cái dự án đấy nó lại có thể thấy
là nó sẽ rồi thêm thời gian chứ không
còn là hai ba tháng nữa thành ra là mô
hình thác nước nó phù hợp cho cái dự án
Ừ cố định thời gian hơn
à à
ở top đồ án tốt đồ án thì chắc sáng là
mấy ông sẽ xin được việc lúc đấy mấy ông
mấy ông sướng thế tôi có sướng gì đâu
không ạ
kết quả quà tôi hứa hẹn cho bé ông nhiều
hướng mấy ông thích gì cũng được tùy
xe đẩy sẽ gọi là gì nhỉ
[âm nhạc]
đồ án lập trình web cơ bản
sẽ làm gì tôi sẽ gửi cho béo mày cái
link này nhé
à à
cô gái gái tôi gửi mấy ông
ở miếu thích thể thao buổi chiều à
Vì con cần gì đó Nhặt với ông bổ sung
tôi này không thì à Ok bây giờ bắt đầu
buổi họp với bộ Hôm nay tôi bảo Rất dài
Tôi xin lỗi Bây giờ mới bắt đầu vào học
rồi Xin lỗi nhé nhờ mấy ông màng nhĩ cần
thêm cái gì thì cứ nhặt cơ bình luận ở
đây để tôi góp ý thêm nhé Đúng rồi nâng
cao cái đoạn thành còn dài nữa nhiều với
lại yêu cầu rồi này Mẹ không xác định
dần đi
xe nâng cao nó dễ dài hơn ở đoạn này bà
mấy cái đoạn này mấy ông phải tự làm này
thế nên là đồ án 1 là tôi hướng dẫn từ a
đến z đón hay là tài liệu hay PowerPoint
mà ông rất là nó sẽ phải tự biết
ở cơ sở dữ liệu và thực thể thì tôi chỉ
chữa Thôi tôi không Tôi không dạy lại
cái này mày ông sẽ phải tự biết thuyết
trình rất là mấy ông sẽ phải tự biết nốt
này tay
tôi chỉ dạy cho mấy ông đúng đúng cái
kiếm nước thôi Còn đâu toàn bộ những cái
Con lạy mấy ông phải tự là để đồ ăn hàng
như thế
ông ngoại Khi nào bắt đầu làm à khi nào
mới ông à
ở buổi hôm nay tôi dậy mấy ông xe Road
cơ bản đúng không ạ xong rồi những buổi
sau tôi sẽ dạy cho mấy ông đầy đủ những
cái làm được từng tính năng từng tính
năng nhỏ
Ê mấy ông lúc đấy cũng có thể bắt đầu
ngồi làm rần trước về giao diện cá thứ
chả tôi và cái vụ kiểm tra định kỳ này
cho tôi phải nói rõ ra là thằng tuần ở
đây là
hàng tuần
Ừ tối thứ 7 đi Nói chung à à
ở
mỗi cuối tuần đi
cái tôi tôi sẽ giao cho Cứ mỗi một tuần
tôi sẽ lại yêu cầu là mấy ông
ăn
mì ông sẽ phải làm thêm một cái gì đó
đúng ạ cứ sau 1 tuần là tôi sẽ yêu cầu
là trong tuần này mày ông sẽ phải làm gì
đó
Anh đuổi tôi chẳng đuổi thì mấy ông cả
nhưng mà vợ cái việc là
nếu mếu không đủ không đúng tiến độ này
cũng như là tự ý sửa một cái gì đó Nói
chung là không đúng tiến độ và tự ý sửa
lộ trình Mấy ông không theo không theo
như tôi
cho tôi tôi không giao trong mấy ông bắt
buộc À ông nào phải giấu bóng nào nhé
Còn nhóm yếu thì tôi sẽ yêu cầu dễ này
và mỗi tuần chỉ cần làm trong được một
vài tính năng bé này chẳng hạn đúng
không ạ
à còn nhóm nhóm khá thì tôi bắt Yêu cầu
phải nâng cao hơn nữa ạ thấy cả thế
nghĩa là nhóm nào mà tôi đây tôi thì
ba lần cảnh cáo
Ừ thì sẽ không được bảo vệ
thế thôi con điểm nhất trí đơn giản
không ạ Ừ đúng rồi Cái này là áp lực cái
này sẽ khi có bạn xong thì các bạn thứ
nhất là nếu mà các bạn học đại học vẫn
còn đang học đại học thấy cái này sau
cái bảo vệ ở trên trường của mấy ông ấy
có khi trả lại cái gì đấy và những ông
nào mà đang đi làm các thư số mà béo lại
thấy cái này sẽ đã cũng tương đối thôi
nhưng mà nó rất là nghiêm túc đúng không
ạ để mày mày ông cậu nhìn vào mấy ông
khi học xong mấy ông sẽ thấy da mình
thay đổi ra rất nhiều rồi
Em hôm nay có mấy buổi đầu dạy về cái á
cô dạy cái máy thứ mà Mấy ông là chỗ mà
cứ bắt kịp thôi
chỉ vài tuần nữa thì mày ông bắt đầu lên
lo là sợ có theo kịp hay không nhưng
không sao ạ
sự thật phải sợ mấy ông đi làm
cái này Nói chung là xong cái này mấy
ông sẽ biết được là mấy ông phù hợp với
ngành này không à
Ừ nếu mà quen với việc áp lực quen với
làm được những cái này đúng ạ
Ừ thì chả là béo đi làm được mà đi làm
lương cao loi Tôi đang hướng đến cho mấy
ông rồi đi làm một phát là làm được luôn
và làm nâng cao chứ không phải làm đi
còn làm cho vui hay Có những thứ mình
Văn được ạ ạ
Ừ ok tổng thống nhất rồi nhá bắt đầu học
nha Ok không
Ừ rồi buổi học hôm nay thì à nhưng mình
đã nói là làm cái CRD không ạ sẽ rủ rê
đó là crash street update và Delete đ
em đứng yên ở khi mà dịch ra toàn gọi là
xem thêm sửa xóa
bởi vì sao Bởi vì là bởi vì là mình đôi
khi mình thường hay làm trước phải giao
diện xem sau đó thì làm do diện thêm sửa
xóa Nhưng thực tế là sẽ load nó mới là
chuẩn các bạn phải tạo trước phải Insert
vào trước phải có dữ liệu trước thì các
bạn mình xem được không ạ Lúc lâu Chả có
gì cả đấy bạn xem cái gì trong ạ và các
bạn sửa xóa cái gì đâu ạ không có lẽ đầu
tiên có bạn phải thêm mới trước đã Thì
hôm nay làm việc sẽ làm việc với bên mái
quý cao thì nếu các bạn mở shopee hoặc
mở level rồi thì các bạn sẽ gõ local hot
như thế này sau đó thì gạch chéo pp máy
pin như thế này đủ ạ
a a a
chế độ xoay kiểu như này thì nó sẽ ra
giao diện của cái
giao diện của cái phần bên 383 ê ê
Anh thường là nó sẽ ở trên là rút và
dưới à Không có không có mật khẩu kiểu
như này
khi đôi khi là các bạn không hiển thị
giao diện này đó có bạn đăng nhập vào
thẳng luôn đấy
thì mình sẽ bạn tạo ra tao bây giờ nó để
cái cái này một là các bạn thấy ghi cốt
toàn đi câu Apple rồi nhưng mình không
dậy hay là cái này nó hỗ trợ Minh kéo
thả để mà làm nhanh thì tôi sẽ dùng cái
làm nhanh nhá không ôn lại được dùng câu
lệnh đâu
chưa bao giờ sự bây giờ mình sẽ đặt tên
là Giêsu school được ạ Các bạn sẽ chọn ở
đây với máy quen nó có thêm những cái để
mà chọn xem là ngôn ngữ các bạn lưu lại
là gì còn nhớ n ve.cha là cả ba cha
không ạ thì trong này nó sẽ quy ước
thẳng luôn Collagen nghĩa nó là các bạn
sẽ dùng cái gì thì cắm các bạn nên kéo
xuống dưới cùng mà chọn cái này utf-8
MP4 Loc anh ạ
Ừ cái các bạn sẽ nghĩ ra mà Tại sao
không phải ở uts 84 Vietnamese mình
người Việt mà đúng không Bởi vì mình
muốn hỗ trợ cho cậu đa ngôn ngữ từ các
cảng trên Oxy và cái unicol này mình nhớ
lọ nào giống nhau như Galaxy này lưu
được cả thêm mấy cái biểu tượng nữa Tôi
hỗ trợ từng dính cái vụ bốc nó có liên
quan gì tượng mặt cười lại nó xin lỗi cả
bạn Nếu xảy ra các bạn nên chọn là kẻ
Galaxy này mấy bốn nó sẽ rộng hơn so
kute 8 bình thường Thế nên là các bạn cứ
chọn cái này là chuẩn nhất này không ạ
đó thế để tạo đâu rồi
ở đó sao bây giờ sẽ tạo bạc thì mình
muốn dạy các bạn là làm đầy đủ tính năng
xem thêm thử Xóa sinh viên chết hả bạn
hoặc à trang tin tức đi thằng tin tức
nhé Sang tin tức của mình sẽ lưu lại
những cái gì mình vẫn thường Lưu lại cột
Mã này không ạ sau đó thì cột à mà sửa
đã kêu đề đi tiêu đề này
nội dung này là cái ảnh nữa chẳng hạn
đấy chứ Còn bốn cụ đơn giản như thế này
Đấy thì mình sẽ là tin tức như thế này
muốn cột ông ạ
thì mình sẽ quét mã này hiểu nè mình sẽ
tích và vệ ai ở đây ai ai ở đây không
phải là chỉ tự nhiên tạo ra đây ở đây
auto mình là tự động tăng của thằng Mai
quen nó thế còn trong Apple server mình
tưởng họ có nói lên tí ti nó tự động
tăng ấy thì trong này like rồi đấy tôi
quên mình không ạ mặc định là sự tích và
luôn là của ai kia quá trình luôn và đây
sẽ là tiêu đề
ông chủ đề này mình sẽ ra tra và mình sẽ
phải khai báo độ dài nóng ạ Nó sẽ cho
mày nhưng mình vẫn nói Luca Legends Mình
sẽ lưu được à Thiệu nó Unicode 20 rồi
mình không cần lại nợ và ra đây không có
được cá tra nội dung này
Hà Nội dung lưu nhiều mình để giảm tách
à bà cũng là cái ảnh cái ảnh ấy thì hôm
trước có bạn hỏi mình là ảnh thì em lưu
lại trên da ta bây Mình sẽ lưu lại gì
thì có bạn trả lời là lưu lại theo kiểu
là mã hóa lại ảnh theo dạng là mây cốt
64 Thực ra đấy một cách thuộc cách
thường hay làm hơn thì nó lưu lại đừng
dẫn này
thì đường dẫn ảnh thì nó đường link của
mình cái ảnh đấy
đường link đến ảnh đấy thì thì đương
nhiên là dạng chữ rồi không ạ thì mình
có thể để tách hoặc cả batra 200 và thư
giãn lắm giờ thoải mái rồi Đường lên nữa
chị 200 thôi bạn kia hỏi unique unique
là cái này bấm vào đây sẽ có nick nè
mục tiêu đề của mình có thể để Yoona
cũng được ăn theo tựa đề 50 cho hơi ít
mình có thể để lên phần ái trăm cũng
được ra thoải mái đúng lắm đó
ở đây đây sẽ có đã tới bây giờ mình xếp
này gọi thế sao không cần phải cút các
thư nữa nhưng mà tôi dậy mấy ông kia để
méo hình dung được cái này rồi đó bạn ok
rồi
ạ bây bây giờ thì mình sẽ làm gì Bây giờ
mình một là mình ấn in sát thủ công ở
trên này Nhưng mà thường là không thế
thường là bây giờ sửa mình sẽ có một cái
trang web để cho những cái ông nhà báo
những ông đều báo cải đúng ạ bé ông ấy
sẽ
có một cái giao diện để mấy ông ấy điên
điền điền điền trong cái phom thôi mày
ông ấn OK thì nó sẽ lưu lại trong bê này
xong rồi ông ấy có thể ấn vào trang chủ
Hiển thị tất cả bài báo chẳng hạn đồng
loại thì đầu tiên thì bây giờ mình sẽ
cốc ta cả trang đấy à
Ờ thì đầu tiên vào cái xanh của mình là
local host này cái chéo school này tôi
có mục tiêu school rồi cốt cũ hôm trước
Xóa hết rồi thì đầu tiên bây giờ vào thì
các bạn sẽ có thể có cái file có sẵn một
cái phone để mày in search sẽ đặt tên nó
là performance cả lại
FPT thì nó hiểu là có một cái phone
cái mà điền thông tin của cái bài báo
đúng ạ là tiêu đề
I
Tech này tiêu đề em ạ
nội dung
thay caro này
là Linh ảnh cả nào
Tại sao Minh ảnh với vì như tôi vừa nói
là lưu lại cái Linh ảnh thôi tôi chưa
dậy mấy ông về vụ rồi có thể đăng được
cái ảnh lên đâu nhé Chưa chưa dậy muộn
đấy mình mới chịu đơn giản nói điêu lại
đường dẫn ảnh và lấy ảnh từ trang web
khác thôi
thêm cả nào ạ
Em bấm vào đây này sẽ ra được cái for
kiểu ngay
khi tải xong mấy ông Điền tiền điện
Nokia thì nó sẽ lưu lại được một cái bài
bằng một cái bài báo đúng không ạ
à à
Ừ thì ở tôi thử lên trang trang Dân Trí
này sẽ có một cái phải báo về đi đây có
phê này có đẹp không mà
xe tải
mục tiêu đề này nội dung này là sự góp
Nếu mẹ không có kiểu như thế này thì ông
thấy rõ ra là nó vào đây nó sẽ không ra
được cái ảnh vui vẻ Đây techapple là chị
lưu lại được chữ thôi làm nó lấy được
cái ảnh giống như mấy thằng này làm là
chè được cái ảnh vào giữa thậm chí có
nhiều ảnh hay nhiều cả video nữa cứ thì
cái này nữa à mình phải áp dụng cái cũng
phải áp dụng thêm thư viện một vài thư
viện nữa businessweek về mà lưu lại được
rất nhiều cái thì cái đấy là tôi vì sao
tôi còn hệ dễ chỉ trong mấy ông này có
thời gian còn không tôi chỉ dậy chỉ
trong mấy ông có bạn với cậu ngay thôi
ta một bài chỉ có một cái ảnh và thường
ảnh trên cùng nhận gì đấy à
anh không Hồng tôi chưa dậy méo về vụ
atransfer ai đâu
ở đó sau đó khi đưa có mượn hàng ngày
đúng ạ anh ấy
an ninh thế copy Inn Express hỏi xem ở
đây đây đuôi chấm tivi rồi này tại ra
cái ảnh ở đông lại đây đường dẫn ảnh đây
là đương nhiên như mình đã nói gì đây
lấy ảnh từ trang web khác tất cả trang
ấy mà xóa sự hàng này đi cái cái cái
đường Linh này lỗi dùng ạ Vì sao tôi sẽ
dạy mấy ông à là mình sẽ lấy ảnh từ
chương trình máy mình ở để lên sau
nhờ có từng bước từng bước ạ Nhưng tôi
đã nói thì khi bây giờ mày Ông bấm thêm
thì mặc định thứ nhất ở nó sẽ nói lại
chính cái file này bởi vì nó nó không
nghỉ đi đâu cả thứ hai nó đẩy hết thêm
thay địa chỉ kiểu như này bởi vì mấy
thước nó mấy thứ ghét đúng ạ Nếu phải
đổi nó thì nhớ là mấy thứ là mấy thức
post để mà đầy được nhiều và đầy Sang
trang khác thì nó sẽ là ác chân xanh
mình sẽ là tên là vô xét tin sub.pro ạ ạ
ở đây cách tôi đặt t thôi cho có mấy ông
dễ hình dung tài hiểu đây là Insert là
thêm nữa ông ạ Cũng giống như đây form
này đây phải xử lý này nó sẽ hợp lý
anh méo để tiếng Việt cũng được đúng
không sao cả Nhưng mấy ông lên thống
nhất cái là tên mình có nửa nạc nửa mỡ
nó hơi bị loạn loạn Nếu phải tải lại
trang nữa không ạ tại
Em
đừng giận ảnh
A và đây sẽ phải bài báo đúng
em
làm thêm à
ở đó Bây giờ nó bảo 404 cho là không tìm
thấy file đấy thế bây giờ mình sẽ tạo
phải đấy thôi
à à
hai
tay này là phải xử lý thì không cần HTML
thì cả nó sẽ chỉ có kiểu thẻ Pepe như
thế này xong rồi xử lý thì thôi tay này
sẽ là bản thân Bây giờ mình sẽ cần làm
những gì thì sẽ lấy toàn bộ những cái đã
điền vào form sau đó thì kết nối đến đã
ta bây để mà sau đó kết nối đến cái đặt
vào đây sau đó thì Insert vào trong cái
bảng này đúng ạ thì đầu tiên thì mình
lấy những cái thứ mình đã nhập về thì ở
đây có tiêu đề nội dung ảnh này mình sẽ
là tiêu đề này bằng đô la poste tiêu đề
này à
ở đây nội dung này
ở đây là ảnh
Mình muốn kết nối đến cái DB thì mình sẽ
phải có một cái Hàn để mà cái nồi để mai
que sẽ tôi thừa là tên nó cái nồi nhà
chẳng hạn bằng máy cao y con ếch thế này
chữ cái Hàn này là hàm để kết nối thì
cái DB được ạ thứ nhất là máy kia có ông
hình dung được rồi Mình đã dùng máy của
em tại sao phải thêm Còn chữ i ở đây bởi
vì hồi trước có cái Hà mãi queo và máy
Core i7 đây phiên bản nâng cấp hơn ở chợ
input và nâng cấp hơn của cái hàm cũ bây
giờ người ta không dùng với 2 máy cao ơi
kiu ngày nữa mà bây giờ nó có nó lại như
thế này nên là mấy ông mà cái sắp lai
tách đôi khi là của tôi nó vẫn còn gợi ý
cái hàm cũ méo mày không không có chữ y
được bọn nó chắc chắn sẽ lỗi đây nhá Đây
là mấy ông bắt buộc phải gõ lên kia tôi
nhá Đừng có theo gợi ý của thằng sau
Pantech không mấy ông lại chửi nó ngu có
mặt trong này mình sẽ phải truyền những
cái gì trong này nó sẽ phải truyền bốn
cái một cái là đầu tiên nó lâu của hot
như thế này trước à máy chủ của ông máy
chủ của ông đều đều là
nếu mà Mấy ông cài trên chính máy ông ấy
nói như nó là lâu nó cô hot kiểu ngay
thôi Được ạ tiếp theo là tên tài khoản
tới tài khoản vừa rồi mình có nói nó rút
mặc định root và tiếp theo là mật khẩu
mật khẩu của mình cũng mặc định sẽ sống
chẳng có gì cả tiếp theo nữa là tên của
đóm bay trên tay của mình là School
không ạ lại school
gì này đó sau đó thì câu câu truy vấn
của mình sẽ câu esquire đúng ạ sẽ bằng
Insert into tin tức các bạn nhiều cái
này không ạ sau đó thì tiêu đề này Hà
Nội dung này và ảnh này đúng không ạ thì
sẽ có ba lô nó như này
Ừ
cái này
Ừ cái bản thân đấy tất cả cái này đều là
chuỗi thì phải để ông chồng ngáy không ạ
thì cái này mình sẽ đạt
nhái này đôla tiêu đề đây rồi phải là
nháy đây nội dung này phải này anh đây
có chứa
cái cái này nó đang biển màu cho các bạn
Các bạn thấy rõ ràng đây là biến của nó
biết lấy từ trên này lấy về và cái này
Bộ ngại két thì nó mới hiểu Đây là biến
đúng bọn đây tất cả Bây giờ mình lấy
toàn bộ những cái thông tin mình nhập về
cho mình che nói trong câu truy vấn như
này đúng không ạ những để chạy được câu
truy vấn này thì mình sẽ phải như sau
mình sẽ phải Michael J aziz
sau đó thì có đến kết nối được gọi đến
câu ashworth như thế này thì rất là nó
mới kết nối và nó mới Sự Chạy câu truy
vấn này của bạn đâu ạ
anh đấy Đấy là như này đã chạy được rồi
em mình phải chạy thử mày ông nhá á
vì nó không báo lỗi gì cả
Ừ cái việc nó không bảo lỗi ở đây tất cả
thằng pê nó nó hiểu được tất cả các hàm
này đúng nhưng mà nó không hề báo lỗi
của thằng Mai kéo nó chạy đua không nên
là đôi khi mày ông sẽ thấy à Rõ là cốt
các bạn có vấn đề gì đây giả sự gõ sai
chữ in sơ như thế này cảm ạ
Nó vẫn không báo lỗi gì cả đúng không ạ
nhưng mà các bạn vào kiểm tra ở trong
này thì nó không ra gì đâu ạ Nên là các
bạn phải đôi khi các bạn sẽ phải in lại
cái câu lệnh này và chạy thủ công Trà sử
do sự như thế này tôi thử inna cầu rõ
ràng cho thằng say nha đúng không ạ Đây
như này là sự không có bạn này tồn tại
là thế nữa không ạ thì các bạn có thể
dùng echo hòa dùng đai 3 như thế này à
Cậu s kyoudai Tức là sao đai Tức là nó
sẽ là vừa là echo
để in in ra
câu chuỗi
nhưng mà đã bày tất cả nó còn có tác
dụng nữa là dừng Ngay tại dừng Ngay tại
dòng đấy nghĩa là đoạn dưới đây là không
chạy nữa dừng Ngay tại đây thôi để mà
các bạn phù hợp với việc các bạn đi bốc
về kiểm tra xem là là câu truy vấn này
nó đang đúng hay sai và đoạn dưới không
cần chạy nữa không ạ Nếu tôi thì phải
dùng hàng Đa Như thế này là sự tôi sẽ
đây câu nói ra thì ông sẽ thấy nó sẽ ra
câu cả câu dài dòng nha các bạn sẽ copy
câu này xanh thẳm bên này thì mới chạy
Ừ thì ông sẽ thấy là nó sẽ báo lỗi bảo
lỗi là tại ngay tại chợ y này và báo
cảnh báo đỏ Đây này chữ in rồi đó không
đúng này và sự với mình có lại đầy đủ in
xơ chẳng hạn Hãy gõ lại này Bây giờ nó
báo lỗi tiếp là cái bảng này không tồn
tại để đúng không Thì ông sẽ sửa dọn ở
trong này là sự như hai chẳng mấy ông
sửa sao béo sang bên này tải lại tra tại
nó ra chồng mày đúng rồi Copy lại cho
phát này ấn vào này nó bảo bây giờ chạy
được đúng ạ
Bây giờ thì đi xuất thành công rồi không
ạ
à à Mày không thể nước Rose này để xem
này cái có hai cái sự thành công rồi
chúng mày không thấy tao ra vẫn còn bị
nhược điểm đó là tuổi như tôi vừa nãy
nói đó là con lây sân này có lây sân có
thể lưu lại tiếng Việt rồi nhưng mà đây
Các bạn thấy tiếng tiếng nó vẫn hay ngôn
ngữ gì nó không ra hẳn tiếng Việt đúng
không ạ Nó vẫn đang bị kéo Dạ giống kiểu
bị mã hóa gì đó là bởi vì khi kết nối
này mấy ông vẫn phải thêm một lần nữa để
mà chắc chắn nó tiếng Việt thì mày ông
sẽ phải thêm lần nữa là ma cao yz tra
xét như này cái cái cái nỗi này mình
phải thêm utf-8
để hiểu nó unikode đúng không ạ
Anh xóa cái này đi kia các bạn chạy được
rồi này Đây Rồi ta lại cho phát nữa đây
rồi ấy mà
ăn rau để xem à
ở đó mèo không thấy tiếng Việt ổn rồi
này
ở đâu ạ
anh ấy tôi cứ xóa trước hai cái này nhé
em có nhiều Bây giờ không có gì đi
chạy lại phát sợ đây
Ừ ok chưa ổn rồi là ngon
Ừ nếu không phải rõ ràng vừa rồi nó lên
hàng à cho
nó lên thành bún thay vì 12 rồi Nó bỏ
qua ba đúng bởi vì tôi nếu mà ông để kỹ
và vừa nãy tôi để tiêu đề nó unique
thành ra là khi mà tôi xuất thành công
đúng rồi nó đang bị lặp lại sau cái tiêu
đề kia nên nó không nên rất được vào
Ai ngờ nó vỡ không bảo lỗi nhưng tôi đã
nói là cái thằng này nó không báo lỗi gì
cả đúng ạ Nếu hôm ấy ông muốn để mày in
lỗi thì mới ông sẽ có kẹo có hàm là má
kéo y Hero như này thì vậy cái nối như
này
và mình sẽ cho một cái biến trà sự lại
biến lỗi ạ Như thế này và mình hình như
ý cho thôi nhờ không làm mình nhớ cho
được cái lỗ này vậy nó chạy thử nhé ạ
ở đấy có sẽ bảo lo sẽ nó sẽ in ra lỗi
nếu có thôi nếu có thôi chả sử bây giờ
là
anh không Không có thằng nào này ạ
Sau đó các bạn thấy không đi ra lỗi gì
nữa được ạ Đấy nếu cho thấy có lỗi thì
các bạn ấy đi lỗi thôi đồng loại
anh và thêm một cái nữa các bạn cần phải
biết đó là cái việc này cái Mai kia con
nít này nó luôn là Mở kết nối đến cái đã
37 các bạn mà nó không hề tự động đóng
ở Vạn - kia các bạn tắt hẳn máy Hòa tắt
cài shopee tắt cày la ngon thì nó mới nó
mới đóng còn không người nó sẽ mở kết
nối khá nhiều rất nhiều pha nó cứ mở kết
nối Thế nên là các bạn khi mà chạy Xong
các câu truy vấn như này xong hết rồi
Các bạn nên thêm một cái là lâu là để
đóng nó lại đúng ạ Không thì các bạn mở
lên quán nhiều nhiều không nhiều ông máy
kiểu xịn xịn ram cái thứ thứ không sao
nhưng những máy mài ông cùi mẹ ông mở
nhiều cái nối thì nó sẽ có thể bị treo
luôn cái máy queo À
ở đảo Vừa rồi tôi dậy khá là trận không
biết mày ông có theo kịp không để mà làm
vụ in such đúng ạ Cái hôm nay có khi
không xong được cái dù tính năng thêm
sữa xóa đâu
bố mẹ tôi
em thử tải lại trang này in xơ cho mấy
ông mày đó mày Ông thấy biết ơn xuất rồi
nên nó sẽ báo lỗi này loạn
thế Nhưng bây giờ có bỏ qua đã tặng xóa
đi á Bây giờ mình làm tiếp tính năng xem
nhé
Từ Thế hôm nay chắc là chị mỗi ạ
anh sửa thêm mới xem thôi sửa xóa cho để
buổi sau vậy à
khi bé làm tính năng xem
thì ở xem ở đây Hiện tại thì mình sẽ có
hai khái niệm xem một là mình xem à tất
cả tất cả các bài đăng đã có
và về sau mình thì làm thêm tính năng là
Xem cụ thể một bài đang ở đó ví dụ là
giống như trang Dân Trí này các bạn thấy
cũng thế thôi sao Dân Trí này là khi mặc
định vào thì nó sẽ ra xem tất cả các bài
đăng có nghĩa là nó chỉ có tiêu đề cùng
lắm là thêm cái ảnh và thêm cái Mô tả
tóm tắt đúng ạ Đấy thì còn là
em còn xem chi tiết bài đăng thì có bạn
sẽ bấm cụ thể vào đường link mà nó lại
xem chi tiết bài đăng thì cái vụ mà hôm
nay chắc tôi hướng dẫn cho mấy ông xem
xem
31 xem tất cả 7 Nam và xem chi tiết bài
đăng còn hôm sau làm thì nó sửa xóa sau
à à
Ừ đúng rồi bạn kia vừa hỏi con rất hay
vào bạn ở dưới cũng trả lời được đúng
rồi đó là hồi trưa và học SQL Server mà
bây giờ tự nhiên nhảy sang là mẹ queo có
gì à pp thì nó lại cái nồi được với mai
que thôi không kết nối được vé Q show
thức là hình như nó cũng có nhưng mà nó
lằn hơn
Ừ nhưng mà ờ
anh nói chung là việc là mấy cái này nó
cũng bản chất nó vỡ lại netware đấy nó
nó không khác biệt nhau lắm không quan
trọng lắm nên việc đấy đâu
à mình mình mình vẫn chỉ quan tâm về
việc là mình thao tác bằng ngôn ngữ lập
trình nào và thao tác với cơ sở dữ liệu
là như thế nào thôi đồng loại mình học
là mình học bản chất giải quyết bài toán
trước mình không cần học
anh đi bằng phương tiện nào giống như
cái ôm bây giờ ông đi màu xe xe Wave hay
là xe gì thôi không quan tâm bây giờ
quan tâm về việc này ông ông biết được
đừng đi vào ông đi như nào thôi không ạ
đó sôi tiếp theo là mình sẽ làm tình
tính năng thường mình sẽ đặt tên cả Đó
là view ô hay cái gì đó nhưng mà Theo
như chuẩn đấy Theo như chuẩn ở thưởng
nhiều người hay đạt được sẽ là trang để
mà vào pháp và thấy luôn Giống như trong
Dân Trí này vào phát ở Sài đua này thì
tên file sẽ phải là file Index II a
further chấm pp này đó là như này cơ
thấy hiểu là vào cái đập vào mắt ông sẽ
ra Hiển thị tất cả bài đăng đã có đấy Nó
là kiểu thế Đây là trang chủ em ạ
Vậy thôi để trong cơ thể hát một chỗ to
đi
về
để mặc khi mà mới vào trang kiểu trang
web của mấy ông ta sẽ mặc định sẽ vào
trang Index kiểu như này đúng không ạ ạ
ở
đại hiện tại thì đương nhiên là mấy ông
thế là chồng chẳng có gì cả Không ạ Bây
giờ làm thế nào để mà Hiển thị tất cả bé
đang bây giờ là muộn thì mới Hiển thị
tất cả bé đang thì
mình lại phải kết nối nó tụi bay lấy tất
cả 7 đang về với nó ra thôi đó ạ thì
mình sẽ là có phê như này mình sẽ là
thì mình sẽ phải ghi lại câu kết nối vẫn
là điều khúc đấy vẫn là điều cũng đấy
nhá mình mình thể copy đây này cho nhanh
này vẫn điều đấy đây
anh như này
ạ Và bây giờ mình sẽ câu truy vấn hả cậu
atwell bằng select sao for tin tức lấy
tất cả 7 đang về này à
ạ sau đó đi mình sẽ vẫn vẫn chạy thực
hiện câu truy vấn đấy nhưng lần này mình
sẽ có cái biến ở biến kết quả
Tức là sao là khi mình
chạy câu truy vấn rồi mình sẽ cần trả về
kết quả trong việc biến đấy nó khác với
cái bên này bên này các bạn thấy mình
chẳng cần có tạo biến khi mà chạy câu
truy vấn vì công y sót xong nó chẳng trả
lời gì cả Mình không còn quan tâm còn
cái sẽ lách thì mình cần trả về Kết quả
nó sẽ trả lời cái quả trong người biến
này đấy
ạ sau đó thì tôi thường hay làm là
Ừ
tôi làm giao diện như cả đơn giản theo
kiểu trong thuê bồ nhé á
ở
trong cái thấy bồ đi
Tại tôi sẽ có là
đây rồi này
th ở đây mình sẽ là mã này
thiếu đê
nội dung và cái ảnh thật à
ấn vào đây mình sẽ có khái niệm vòng lặp
for acts như thế này
để cho béo hình dung ảnh iPhone X ra nó
rất mới đối với mấy ông có ích nè Nó gì
có cái nghề tức là lấy phuacs bản chất
là nó sẽ duyệt duyệt Ford tất à Việt mà
nó vòng đặt vào giống vàng là pho nhưng
vòng lặp này vòng lập để chuyên diệt mà
đâu ạ Nó sẽ duyệt từng kết quả trong cái
mạng thế
này thành từng cái bạn ghi một ở đây
mình sẽ là tên để ít chẳng lại a d gọi
từng bài báo này từng bài tin tức các
bạn
đã hiểu như này đúng ạ Nó sẽ diệt từng
hàng và ý đã từng hàng một có bao nhiêu
thằng kết quả là sự im lặng bấy nhiêu
đấy tác dụng của cậu là phối
và cái kết này thì ra cái việc này cứ
viết tắt của cái pp Thôi thì là các bạn
viết thì nó có thể viết nó thành kiểu
nhà cơ
ở đó là kiệm như này
các bạn này mình đang làm này tức là sao
nghĩa là có bao nhiêu bài đăng được lắm
ạ
thì mình sẽ in là bấy nhiêu cái ở đây
đây mình cho bạn xem này
thì mình sẽ để cho nó 1 cái poder là một
và quýt là một trăm phần trăm
nghìn cho đẹp tí đã có bao nhiêu bài
đăng thì tôi sẽ in mấy nhiều dòng ở đây
nó sẽ dạng như này thì đây nè
ạ
sau đó đi chùa ở đây là từng bài tin tức
tại mã này tiêu đề
nội dung này và ảnh đấy à
ở các kiểu nhà
Ê mấy ông thấy à tiếng Việt ở đây là này
lại lỗi rồi đúng ạ Vì như tôi vừa nãy
nói là các bạn sẽ phải thêm cái ô tế 8 ở
ngay đoạn trên này như thế này
đó Ok chưa
do đó Nếu thấy được ra Hà Nội dung mà hư
rất dài mấy ông thích thì mày không thể
dùng hàm cắt chuỗi ấy và cả thậm chí à
Ừ tôi sẽ tạm bỏ nó đi đã Tôi muốn kia
lúc đầu nó chưa có tiêu đề kháng cái ảnh
thôi khi em bấm mà xem chi tiết thì nói
như đĩa nội dung sau cũng được không ạ
Ừ thì ở đây mếu thấy ảnh này Thực ra nó
vẫn không phải là cái ảnh có dòng Linh
đúng thì cái bản chất ở đây mình sẽ phải
thay thế giới đây nó thấy Maria nếu học
rồi mà ông ạ gì mà cờ sau đó thì LC là
nhảy đến từng bài tin tức tại ảnh Nếu
thấy ở đây tôi ghi như thế này tất cả
tên các cột đấy đúng không ạ tên cột ở
trong B mình nhé đó và sẽ ra ngay
em hơi to nhỉ Anh lấy nếu hệ cho nó là
Quýt là
anh alo thương ai trình chiều cao Nó hơn
chị chiều cao cho nó là hai mà 100 hơn
chẳng hạn
ở
đó anh đã sẽ tâm như anh thôi đâu ạ ạ
Ừ thì bây giờ mày ông có thể Đây đây là
đang có một bài đăng không ạ Nếu không
muốn thêm một bài năng nữa thì mới không
có thể thể A ở trên này
cái này
sau đó thì nó sẽ nhảy lên cái file là
Ford shop để mà thêm bài đăng mới không
ạ thêm bài viết trong lại
to như thế này bấm vào đây để sang four
thêm mày viết thôi là sự tôi thêm một
bài mới nhá
ở đoạn này thì tôi tôi nghĩ à Có phải
ông ấy thấy nó chặn rồi phí méo học rồi
có vai ông ấy thấy đoạn này mới thấy khó
vãi Nhưng mà chắc à mày ông sẽ phải xem
lại có thứ cho quen rồi ạ ạ
ở tay thế mày
em không bảo gì không ạ Không bảo gì chứ
cả không có lỗi bạn Bây giờ mình sẽ xóa
các bạn này đi để quay lại trang chủ đây
đó mấy ông thấy có hai bài rồi nó ạ Bây
muốn làm Xem chi tiết 1 bài giờ sự tốt
có cái nút ở đây bấm xem có bấm vào tư
để xem nào ạ đại khái Thế nếu bấm và
tiêu đề để xem thì đây là thảy a này bấm
sẽ xem được khoai lang không ạ thì tôi
sẽ
Uh
cho nó có thể A như thế này
bản chất là khi bấm vào cái này An à nó
sẽ nhảy đến một cái trang và trang tên
là xem nào ạ
Lỡ để hết toàn bộ tiếng Anh nghỉ bây giờ
mình sẽ để tiếng Anh của nó là sau
dich.ve
có
gì này Đấy nó hiểu là bấm vào cái trang
này vào xem được một bài này những phải
Ông thấy là hai đường dẫn này đang giống
hệt nhau là sâu chấm pp.pe số của và
mình không biết được thì bấm vào đây xem
bài đăng này và bấm vào đây xem mày là
ngày nó khác nhau điều gì đó thường là
khác nhau có mã đúng bài đăng này nó có
mã 6 mẹ đang ngày mã 8 và khác nhau qua
Mã thì tất cả khi mình bấm vào đây mình
sẽ hiểu xem mày đang có mã tặng mặt là
Sáu đúng ạ Vì sẽ truyền vào trong này
như này
a mã bằng EXO
ở
tại mã nhà chắc chắn là toàn toàn bộ đây
để toàn bộ kiến thức mới nên là mấy ông
chị sẽ hơi bị khó hiểu ở bị xóa không lý
Bây giờ tôi đang dạy một cách từ từ Đấy
mày ông phải xem đi xem lại
mấy ông cần hiểu rồi nhá hiểu đã nhá con
để làm được cốt từ đầu đến cuối nhưng
tôi như này sẽ trả nước miếng xem một
buổi không thể hiểu đâu mà phải cô đi có
lại nữa
Ừ tôi tí rồi cũng sẽ cân nhắc việc có
nên đăng đoạn đống con này lên không vậy
Đang đoạn này lên nếu copy về mày ông
chạy cái được luôn không hay tôi muốn
mấy ông phải xem lại video này mà nếu
phải gõ lại cơ để cho nó kìa
à à
Ồ không tôi chưa từng nói mấy ông là lập
trình dễ dàng cả trên thế là cái này
chắc chắn lo cho án rồi đây bấm ở đây để
xem một bài bạc một bài này bấm mà ai đã
quên ta lạnh tra đã bấm vào đấy thì các
bạn sẽ hiểu là xem bài có mã là Sáu đúng
ạ
Ê bà bấm vào thì sẽ xem bài có mã 8 đúng
gì đấy
Ừ thì thì cái cái việc Bấm vào để xem
được một vài bài đăng như này mình sẽ
tạo ra file file này đúng không ạ Để xem
tôi sẽ tạo một file mới thế này trâu cho
P này file này thời ga là thực ra là nó
cũng rất là giống cái file ở bên này là
theo kiểu nó cũng sẽ hết sao lấy toàn bộ
đây thấy toàn bộ thông tin từ bản tin
tức chẳng qua nó lấy theo mã của cái bài
đăng này thôi đúng ạ
Ừ
Thì bây giờ mình sẽ là mình sẽ có thể
copy các bạn này Đấy copy đoàn
kết nối vẫn đặt điệp khúc kết nối này
bạn nó quốc tế 8 này không ạ ạ
Ừ nếu mà lần này như tôi nói là chỉ lấy
đúng mỗi cái bài đăng này thôi có mã
bằng mấy thì tất cả mình sẽ phải lấy mã
bằng đôla get lấy ở trên hai địa chỉ về
này và mình sẽ lấy đúng cái bài đăng có
mã là như thế thôi ông ạ que mã bằng
mã ngay à
ở đường Bà nó sẽ trả về kết quả như thế
này nó sẽ trả cái quả trong này
ở đầu tiên bây giờ các bạn thấy em ở
trong trắng trơn Chẳng có gì cả Không ạ
ạ
anh bởi vì mình chữ in ra cái gì cả Bây
giờ để mình in cái kết quả này ra thì
chưa hết thì để tôi nói cái đoạn này cho
mày không còn thấy lũ hơn một tí đấy Cái
túi mày ông chạy code select này nó trả
về Nếu giả sử có mã vào sáu thì đương
nhiên mày Ông thấy nó trả về đúng mỗi
cái bài đăng có mã 6 đúng ạ nghĩa một
bài hơi không ạ một bài thôi đúng không
Nhưng thằng này nó luôn theo cơ chế là
cái bài đấy nó vẫn sẽ là mạ trả qua màn
này có một phân tử được ạ Nó vẫn sẽ là
mảnh ấy nhá nên là mấy ông muốn lấy
thằng đầu tiên từ cái mạng này thì bé
ông sẽ chị sẽ phải là
ờ ờ
ạ trà sữa bài đăng chẳng hạn bài tin tức
muốn lấy thằng đầu tiên thì các bạn sẽ
dùng hàm fake
Town những này để lấy son đầu tiên từ
cái mạng đấy như thế này rồi chị ạ
Vì sao sau đó thì mấy ông ấy in được nó
ra là sự đây tôi nó trong thẻ hắn một
đây ạ Thế cho
bài tin tức tại tiêu đề này à
à Tại mấy ông thầy ra rồi không ạ sau đó
thì mày ông cho thẻ P là nội dung này
ở đó
Ê bà cuối cùng là
emg là cho với ảnh đúng không ạ mày tức
tại ảnh
Ừ anh ở cuối nhé
mình cứ chỉnh lại hay cho nó bằng một
trăm hai trăm gì đấy à
ừ ừ
ở đây thường nhất là tôi sẽ trả lời cho
mấy ông hai câu bạn kia vừa hỏi cậu ra
là đúng Đó là tại sao lại phải dùng
Matit ghét cậu ngay mà không phải mới
thức post của vì à Mấy ông bấm ở trên
đây là mấy ông không phải điện trong cái
phone
để còn biết Post vào máy ông bấm vào
đường link để mà nhảy Sang trang khác
Bấm vào đường link thì nó chỉ có mấy cô
két thôi Thế nên à
mày Ông bấm vào đường link nó sẽ nôn có
nó chỉ mấy thơ két để lấy trên 2 địa chỉ
về vì nó đường link mà nó không phải
phone gì cả chứ không phải là ở đây ông
có một cái nút công bấm vào xong rồi nó
sẽ sắp ít cái for cho ông không không
không vào như này Ừ đúng vậy Thực ra cái
mã của cái bài đăng không cần phải bảo
mật lắm thế này là các bạn để ghét cũng
được có ảnh hưởng gì cả nhiều mấy ông để
chỉ bài báo này thế thôi
ở mọi nơi đều thế nếu để ý kĩ là trên 2
Địa chỉ đây chí ngay đi của bé năng đấy
tôi là tiêu đề nó một kiểu nhưng nó luôn
kèm theo ID đằng sau đúng ạ kể cả bài
Facebook hay bất kỳ cái gì thằng nào nó
cũng có vẻ đi thôi chả quay đi được mã
hoá kiểu kiểu như thế này đấy Con đâu
toàn bộ tất cả đều lại đi hết cái ID trả
lại loạn
đấy thì không phải cái cái cái việc cái
cái
Ừ cái này nó là nó là cơ chế như thế nhé
bấm vào đường link để mở ra được bài
đăng và đương nhiên là đường Linh ấy sẽ
cái máy đi để hiểu được là bạn muốn xem
bài đăng nào đúng không ạ Thế nên là
luôn dùng mấy thứ ghét trong trường hợp
này
cái thứ hai có bạn có thể sẽ thắc mắc đó
là vừa nãy em thấy anh copy cái bài
chính từ bài này thấy nó enter xuống làm
rất nhiều và trong bên đó em thấy ở đây
anh chẳng enter gì cả đúng tại sao như
thế Mọi việc vừa nãy tôi copy ở đây miếu
để ý kĩ a tôi thì nhớ tôi không có pin
thì cái ảnh thứ hai tôi không copy được
cả nó là chữ in nghiêng ạ Hay là chữ in
đậm in hoa gì đó phải in hoa cũng không
không nói gì cho nó in nghiêng này hay
in theo ý nghĩa à in đậm lại 2 á Ảnh này
hay là xuống dòng này Tại sao không copy
được cái đấy thì như tôi đã nói đó là
khi mà đẩy vào cái
khi tách Alo này thì các bạn sẽ không
đẩy được cái cái kiểu định dạng của nó
là kiểu in nghiêng in đậm đúng không ạ
Các bạn chỉ lấy được mỗi chữ thôi nhưng
có bạn sẽ thắc mắc à Rõ ràng là em copy
ở đây một đống vào nó có xuống dòng cơ
mà đúng không ạ Tại sao khi mà anh in ra
nó không xuống dòng Đông ạ vì bản chất
là
các bạn nhớ rồi quy tắc xuống dòng của
bên HTML không ạ Cái này đang in HTML
của bạn bạn nhiều quy tắc xuống dòng
nóng mạ quy tắc xuống dòng của htl phải
dùng thẻ gì ạ
Ừ ông nào trả lời nhanh cho 10 điểm bụi
hôm nay nào
à à
Ừ đúng rồi ông Trần Văn Sơn nhanh phết
đấy phải dùng bây giờ sống dòng đúng ạ
Cái cái cái cái này ra của mình chỉ đang
in ra dạng chữ nếu mở mấy ông ấy ăn cho
new thì đúng là nó có xuống dòng rồi
nhưng mà nhưng mà cái in ra theo kiểu
như này thì nó không có Pro thì ra Nó
cũng thủ dao đơn giản đấy thôi Con thì
cái càng thì ông sẽ thắc mắc à thế cái
súng dòng ở trong này nó không phải bây
giờ thấy nó là cái gì không ạ để khiến
nó xuống dặm như này cái số dòng như thế
này nó quy tắc của bên bên máy tính định
nghĩa nó là
Ừ nó là newlife tất cả nó là
ở gạch chéo nào như thế này đúng ạ bây
giờ để mấy ông muốn đổi gạch chéo này
sang thành Pro thì mới ông sẽ có hàm
không ạ Như like to blow pp
ở đó sẽ Cá Hàn này you like to blow nó
kiểu chữ đoạn lại vãi số 2 đứa thay chữ
Thu cái gì hết vào mấy ông sẽ đổi đoạn
này đây như thế này được ạ hãy dùng cái
hàng như này để toàn bộ chữ cái cái cái
cái chéo nâu đấy nó sẽ tháng tôi tại
trang béo xe này nó đội Anh biết rồi này
đương nhiên ở chỗ này nó sẽ xuống dòng
máy không Ok chưa
a free Tôi khuyên mày không nên dùng
prison nhiều free làm chữ được các bạn
Nhập vào như thế nào nó sẽ ra như thế và
đôi khi là nó sẽ bị lỗi iPhone không
dùng rồi đấy ạ
từ nãy giờ tôi đang dạy ở mấy ông rất
chậm và dạy cho ông mấy ông tất cả những
cái cơ bản và cậu giải thích nữa con trọ
giải thích nữa đâu ạ để giải thích cho
mấy ông nên là tôi hi vọng là mấy ông ạ
Chắc chắn là mấy ông không thấm được
ngay mấy ông bể Cốt lại có đoạn này cá
không nhưng hi vọng là nãy giờ tôi giả
trong mấy ông Độ dễ hiểu để mà Mấy ông
xem lại
mà quan trọng là dễ hiểu đã đúng không ạ
Dễ hiểu để mà mày ông hứng thú xem lại
và xem lại một vài lần mà ông sẽ làm
được đóng lại chứ
từ nãy giờ mày ông khó hiểu đoạn nào đó
ạ
Ừ bố hôm nay sẽ chị lại thôi đó làm chỉ
là
ẩm thực ra không đầy đủ sure they được
đó là trẻ thêm và xem xem tất cả nó
xem cụ thể một bài đăng rồi Hôm sau làm
sửa xóa sau sửa xóa Thực ra ngắn cũng
ngắm thôi ngắn hơn khá nhiều nhưng mà cứ
nghĩ bọn này hơi quá Tại mấy ông nội
ừ ừ
anh nhắc lại hôm ấy ông cài cái đoạn nào
cần nhắc lại với ông tua lại cho tôi nữa
à
ở
tủ lại họ xem lại nha méo ạ
Ừ Ok chị ạ à đúng ơi mấy ông nên nhiều
giống tôi nhá Tôi thỉnh thoảng tôi lại
quên đấy Nhớ tôi bảo rồi máy tôi cũng
khỏe hơn mẹ mày mấy ông cái ông luôn
phải nhờ đóng
đóng con nít nhé
Mà tại sao tôi lại hay quên được đóng
con nách Thế đã từng có Sinh viên hỏi
tôi vụ này đó là tại sao tôi hay quên
đón con ếch anh rõ là anh Bây giờ anh
bảo em đang cố TP nhiều mà Anh làm ở
công ty anh quên đóng con ếch gà tại đồ
hoạ không Bởi vì a Bởi vì khi mà các bạn
cốt sang bên trình nâng cao hơn rồi toàn
bộ những cái tự động được tự động được
nó sẽ tự động được cho ông nên hàng ra
là anh kể cả cái vụ
này cái thứ về sao tôi dậy ông ấy toàn
bụi toàn bộ cái cốt này có thể lên đến
10 dòng cốc thôi Có
mấy ông sẽ thấy à Tôi đang dạy mấy ông
tất cả những cái cơ bản và rất nhiều cái
chưa đơn giản về sau các bạn để làm
những bài toán phức tạp hơi không phải
Quốc dài dòng nghe được Nếu cốt sẽ rất
ngắn và rất dễ sửa tối ưu cứ phân vân
nlu rất rất dễ mấy ông chỉ cần nghĩ ý
tưởng là mà làm thôi
A và tất cả những cái có thể tự động
được nó sẽ tự động hết cho mấy ông rồi
cái tôi đang khoe cho mấy ông sự thật mà
ông về sau có động lực thì em ấy ông
thấy đoạn này trong vậy để làm những cái
rõ ràng cho mẹ đơn giản này cũng mất rất
nhiều nòng cốt trong ạ về sau vài dòng
thôi I
3 cách để đẩy cốc lên ghế thấp
thì tôi từng nói qua đấy vì ông cứ lên
cái khắp tạo một cái Zippo cho nó có
mình ông lưu new file và được mà cái
kiểu hôm trước đây tại một cái Tết đây
này mấy ông ấn vào
Ừ cái Fi này Đấy creat new file sau đó
thì bị ông
khi nhập tên file có thứ chè cốc ở đây
là xong mà
ạ sau đó thì mới ông gửi luôn cả cái
đường link Xipo này ở trên
trang te cái bồ thôi tôi xem là được mà
à à
à còn đâu mà còn thắc mắc gì không
ăn cá không Tôi đang không có ý định là
để cốt lên đâu
chủ đề cốt nên mấy ông có cốt về thì à
không tốt lắm
Ờ Ờ tôi đang buồn mà không có lại tất cả
được mấy cơ Gõ lại nhiều cho anh nhớ
em có quay video mà Mấy ông sẽ phải xem
lại
từ trước khi ở
sự cố của tôi có đủ Nhìn mày không nhỉ
Mạng có bị bé quá không không trước bị
bẻ khóa
Ừ tôi chỉ sợ là chú Đôi khi bé quá mấy
hôm đọc được thôi
ai cho hôm hôm nay chắc là kiến thức đến
đây thôi nhỉ
ở buổi buổi buổi sau sẽ làm nốt Hà và
Chắc là sẽ có thêm một vài cái nữa
bố mày được ra kiến thức nó cũng khá
nhiều đấy đúng
về câu hỏi của bạn vĩnh viễn kia chắc là
buổi hôm sau tôi trả lời nhé anh tra bổ
hôm nay tạm dừng lại đây không nhỉ á
nhon
em có bạn kia khỏi về vụ avatar của tôi
làm như thế nào đúng ạ Ta của tôi dùng
cải trang ah
ở
lại lyrics lyrics poster với ông tra lại
sang này nhé
à à
Ừ đúng rồi hầu như một nữ lập trình nào
cũng có cái con cho họ chẳng qua tôi
không dạy mày không về mày cái đấy thôi
Ừ Ok thôi các bạn có gì thắc mắc thì
bình luận nhé mình xin phép
Cho mình xin phép trả lời sau trả bạn
ừ ừ